ah hello everyone i'm so nervous i'm so scared oh my gosh oh
everyone's practicing so hard i'm oh i'm actually very
nervous today but my team has been practicing very hard as
well sorry we just got out of a scrim and we were like
cooling down from our scrim um we had to like teams are
scrimming teams have been practicing the last very hard the
last two days so um it very scary so we're gonna do a little
quick play we're not gonna leak any strats though because
like it's best of one it's best of one so if we uh we have
one one game versus each team one one game and the top two
teams go into finals and then the other two we leave but no
matter what happens i'm gonna be playing rank until it's
good night dragons uh No matter Either I'm coping Or I'm
celebrating It's one or the other Yes Also we're starting
early The real matches start at 5 They want us to warm up
Like I guess like warm up Like an hour early But then like I
saw Duby hasn't started stream yet So I was just like Yay So
I was just like Okay it's not just me at least So I was just
like Okay it's not just me like but we found out all of us
found out like yesterday I think like lat late last night
that we're supposed to um we're like they were like yeah one
hour early one hour early but that like obviously oh my god
sorry that's like their soundboard I need to turn that on I
really um that is that's the soundboard I do remember how to
turn off like mute other people's soundboard
mute soundboard mute soundboard uh
mute soundboard uh there you go uh wait what about
sorry we're discussing strats i don't want to leak anything
because like we're everyone's trying not to leak anything
because it's best of one and if they know our Everyone's
doing it.
All the teams are doing it.
So, like, if they know our comp, it's, like, GG.
Sorry.
All right, there we go.
Yeah, because, like, if they know our comp, it's just Target
ban.
Yeah, it's just, there's no, it's rank bans.
There's no protect.
So, it's, like, straight up, rank bans.
So, you know, they get two bans.
We get two bans, but we're banning at the same time.
So like but like people are like research everyone almost
everyone locked their profiles to my team locked their
profile as well Because I was like locked a profile because
like I noticed the other Like the cat the usual the the the
rival players that actually play this game a lot They all
instantly locked their profiles the moment like when they
started practicing So I was like told my team lock your
profiles like if they're gonna lock it.
We gotta lock it but
so so like we're trying not to like everyone everyone is
like oh my gosh i know everyone's also having a lot of fun
you know it's obviously it's a lot of fun too but it's very
stressful for me because i got assigned captain um in a
pre-assigned team um so uh okay okay i'm just gonna i need a
copy and paste this so i remember what we're running um like
i have like a guide on like Like, okay, we got to, we banned
this.
We banned this.
I just want to, I hope we win one game.
That's our goal.
Our goal is to win one game.
I, I, I, I believe in this.
We can do it.
I just, I just want us to win one game.
That's my goal.
Like, how, yeah, I just want to win at least one.
All right, here we go.
Um...
Okay, all right, okay.
I'm ready.
Also, are you all up?
Very quick play.
All right, I'm asking if they're ready for quick play now.
All right.
I'm on YouTube.
They're like, let's do share chat.
And I'm like, I'm on YouTube.
hello hello hello hello all right i'll add you guys yeah i
was like hey guys is everyone here i'm so nervous the best
of one is like with me right now what best of one is the
best bro
no no no because think about it right think about it right
you go in you alt immediately you're just going as hard as
possible in the first game you let them know who's winning
and it's us oh oh the thought that you can like make a
really bad misplay and then just lose and get eliminated is
scaring me that's the scary part yeah yeah yeah i thought
like there would be like it's like uh you know round we each
play one game and then we do group stages so it's like yeah
Yeah, but it's best of one and then the two best player
teams you guys have fun
Yeah, yeah, well, it's like it's like it's like we're in
pools and also top 16 at the same time Yeah, you just gotta
you just gotta rock with it, you know.
Yeah, okay.
I am wait, why can't I invite you guys to my team?
Why do you guys have to?
Oh, you blocked us.
I can request.
No, it's like yeah.
Oh, you guys have to request.
Yeah, I like half of no Oh, now I can.
Oh, yeah.
Join the team.
Yeah, you guys got a request to join me.
Apparently, I can't invite people.
I don't know why.
All right, so for this, the black backline will play our
usual characters.
The front, you guys go wild.
The other three, you guys go wild.
Pick whatever the fuck you want.
I can play whoever I want.
You guys play whoever the fuck you want.
Let's go!
I know exactly who I'm playing.
Yeah, you guys pay whoever you want, guys.
oh it's because like some of you guys are like in the uh in
the game that's why okay yeah i was in i was in a practice
range i was like wondering who am i missing oh you use it
yeah yeah yeah sorry the fps counter blocked you from from
your invite all right i'll queue up i'll queue this up whoa
i wonder who we're playing first i wonder if like we all
play at the same time or it's like one by one because it's
like four hours I was like there's no way because matches
are so fast it's like 20 minutes I was gonna say the first
two matches we played simultaneously yeah I don't know I
don't know if they want to cast both of them simultaneously
yeah so I think they're just like we take turns we literally
just wait here one by one until you'll need until like our
game starts again like we're just here watching the other
teams play like I guess I'm ready Wait, aren't we team one
though?
We're team what?
We were first on the list.
I assume that makes us team one.
What?
What list?
Are we?
What?
There's a list?
Wait, we are going first.
The list that we know whose team is whose team.
Or you know what?
Maybe it was alphabetical.
Are you playing whoever right now?
Maybe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The back line, like the supports we play are usual.
The front lines we're hiding.
Yeah, the other three, you guys play whatever the fuck you
would.
Because, like, you know, if you guys play the what we're
actually playing then we're no i'm not bro because i'm
playing the thing or we're playing mind games right now
we're doing mind games you know what we're actually playing
might might actually be what we're actually you know what we
don't even need a tank for real if we just kill them all
yeah exactly i'm playing my main i'm playing my yeah yeah
yeah uh if any of you guys are streaming on twitch and want
to join the shared chat thing i put a link in our team thing
okay joining
haha i'm sorry not i wanted to be on youtube hey that's we
bleed purple around here cut that's captain yeah yeah your
captain's not even on twitch oh my god i'm hitting all my
shots wait they have a tank that's cheating yo what i just
got two no reds oh my god this captain's one all right sorry
oh my god i'll join you sure chat i'm sorry oh you're
joining oh someone's throwing yeah i was joining i was just
i'll join after the game yeah and i swear i'm lagging bro
that's why my shots are missing i i legitimately do feel
like i'm lagging still what you what go back the up emma my
psp like the cloud fuel servers you know i am lagging wow
wait how am i actually lagging at first i was just i was
just trying to like make an excuse i might actually be
lagging i think my frames are just dropping to be honest i
don't know if it might be because of my vtuber model i might
yeah no it does that it does that oh yeah i'm using fugies
only oh okay i'll probably do that oh yeah yeah i have a 59
just because i do this too much heavenly if you don't kill
one person i'm like i'm gonna just one headshot
know what we can i do gambit on and then you all my dps can
just go at it like throw everything what all right i have
gamma on five oh my god you're dead i'm just gonna wait i'm
just gonna wait i'm sorry i don't understand how we're
losing guys i wonder what can we do i don't know looking at
this calm you know what i haven't hit a headshot yet it's
time all right are you guys ready I'm switching.
I'm switching.
Yeah.
Let's do it.
Are you guys ready?
I'm gonna rip it.
Go!
Okay.
Oh, I'm black.
I got one.
Nice.
See?
We rip it.
Oh my god.
Oh, that was awesome.
That was awesome.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
You did it.
See?
Wow.
We swapped with the team.
We literally just went to all three.
Who is that?
Who would have thought we got a team?
easier whoa i'm staggering the hell out of this guy oh wait
man this is by herself come here oh my god oh my gosh guys
oh my god what is he doing here oh nice nice well nice kill
oh my god Oh, the might of...
Oh.
Alright, good job, guys.
That's not my problem.
Good.
Oh my god, what the fuck is going on here?
We don't need all those else, guys.
We...
No, we needed those.
We definitely needed every game button.
No, no, we don't need it.
You have a style on them.
It's, it's like...
Yeah, that's what...
Guys, that is exactly what we're gonna do in the tournament
too.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, for those who are wondering...
Let's kill Blade.
He's by himself.
Yo, look.
There, I got him.
Okay, he's dead.
Oh, my God.
I'm coming.
I anti-4 people.
I got a cat.
Oh, I'm tied in the 10.
They have an Iron Man now.
Yeah, what are they going to do about that?
All right.
Iron Man low.
Zap.
Oh, my gosh.
I fucked up my dash.
All right.
I'm going to anti this.
I got Emma.
Got us.
And she's dead.
I'm on the whole back line.
i am the back like i'm out of here oh you left me bro what
the bro hey listen i threw the hammer you would pull the
whole door bro like oh my god i was in and i was one percent
i could have given you a solo gambit all now you ain't
getting one oh i think we just reset just reset here okay
yeah we did i know we're supposed to be like seriously
playing but um i gotta go answer the door oh i'll swap time
imagine this was the official match where's my wallet uh oh
wait we got pauses for the official match that's good oh
what is this dude what is that i have it oh that's just it's
just damage it's just like you're such a projectile because
of a gambit team up all right like also still experiencing
live not me yeah i think he's one he's one nice we're all
team i'm sorry i got the uh emma though oh he's anti oh it's
fine i don't even know how to shield oh that's how you
shield okay yeah double bubble i have i have invis alt for
this i've never played this guy before uh you can for invis
i'll just use defensively because they do have i have ulti
soon by the way uh invis first and then cloak later okay
captain behind again i got you i got you i got you i can
You're fine.
Oh, no!
He's so fast.
I'm just a little guy.
I don't have any anti, so...
Oh!
He got these.
Yeah, yeah, use this.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
We can cloak out aggressively, we want.
Cloak, cloak out.
Cloak out, cloak out.
Nice, nice.
Outside, outside!
I'm leaving?
Oh, God.
It's my side.
He also hit the wall.
Oh hell yeah, brother.
Oh my gosh.
Entide, Entide, Entide!
Emma, Emma.
I'm low, I'm low.
I'm pushing card, I'm pushing card.
I got you, I got you.
I'm looking cap, I'm looking cap.
I'm looking cap.
There's a gambit behind.
I'm low, I'm low.
It's fine, you're fine, you're fine.
Entide, Invis?
What am I doing?
I'm looking blade, I'm looking blade.
You guys go, you guys go, you guys go.
Disappear!
I'll grab this.
I really want to go.
I got Blading.
I got him right.
Thank you.
Cap one.
Nice, nice.
I'm going to daredevil.
Holy shit.
Nice.
Yeah.
I'm looking given.
I'm looking given one.
Give him one.
Give him this one.
I'm looking blade blade low blade low he's yeah we got it we
got it we got it I'm going back we need to be one on card a
thousand cards and we can use for this if we get cloak all
at first you can use cloak all aggressively here okay I have
ulti by the way also uh he said you got a bubble or cloak I
don't know if you can do that but I don't know if you can't
have that in me I got it.
Okay, so when you hear the iron metal, just bubble or cloak.
Okay.
What's work?
You're an E or F.
All right.
It's E.
Okay.
Use aggressively.
Use your cloak or here.
Use.
Bubble or bubble or bubble.
Nice.
And I don't know if you did it, but like I saw you.
I want a back line.
I need healing.
He just dodged.
Any healing?
I'm dead.
You got this?
Here you go.
You got all.
okay i bubble wolverine though i'm batman ulting i'm batman
ulting nice nice nice nice nice kills oh nice oh my god good
job that's awesome that's awesome good job guys we did it
look at that guys we won our first match everyone best of
all of us did it we all did it and ironically that was my
Alex here.
Hi, I just wanted to say thanks for being part of the event.
And we may be piping in, like, Doki or one of the captains,
like, periodically throughout the event, like to do an
interview, but maybe, like, after a round or two.
Just wanted to give you an update.
Okay.
Thank you.
Awesome.
Have fun, guys.
See you.
Thank you for the invite.
Wait, I had a question.
Um, are we, are the two matches going simultaneously or is
one minute?
going at a time and we just all watch the match that's going
on uh every match should be on stream so you can just uh
yeah just watch so we're waiting oh okay yeah you can just
like co-stream basically okay okay okay sure yeah we we
enabled uh co-streaming for everyone so even on youtube
should be good oh you could you could like just obs it i
guess no no uh co-stream for youtube but if you want to you
know broadcast it it's all good yeah okay um i'll talk with
production just to make sure we're good there but yeah every
match should be on stream so okay okay okay any other
questions uh do we know which team is which teams are going
first yet or no uh the first one is um and i could find out
which one i'm having production like organize the whole
thing at this point okay so yeah i'm i'm the event organizer
so let me come back to you okay i'll be right back okay
thank you okay thank you yeah no problem have fun maybe i
worded those questions kind of weird we got this it's fine i
don't know what that means uh yeah i don't know i think that
means we're allowed to stream it like share like like you
can stream to stream yeah okay because it's technically
against the rules to stream another partner's content unless
they give you explicit permission oh okay well it's it's one
of those rules where like if you do it and the person gets
mad they can report to you but if no one knows then like you
know yeah it's like how you know the game awards they make
you apply to co-stream it yeah it's just that okay but you
know other people you know they can't catch everyone so
streamer they can't catch you right right right all right
i'm ready this time i'm excited yeah let's do we can have a
doing another quick match yeah we can we can i think we can
right i mean we can all just leave afterwards worst scenario
we back out it's fine yeah we're already in i'm
still thinking about that team dookie yeah just confirming
uh the first match is team dubie versus team omelette and if
you're not playing you know you're you're watching every
match okay cool got it okay that's not that's all best of
one so it should be relatively quick make way for the good
luck you got it yeah that's what that's that's what i
thought i was like there's no way they're gonna have us do
like two at a time because they can only commentate on one
at a time so we're just gonna wait did he say we have to
watch the um yeah i think so we have to Yeah, well, okay, we
don't have to.
You could, like, I can't really put it up on my stream, but
I'll just watch it.
Because I do have to know what they're playing.
We haven't.
Time to study.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Actually, I haven't seen any of the teams, the other teams
besides us.
I haven't seen any of them play together.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I like watch some of the replays.
on my put on my nerd glasses and was like brought out the
expo marker started writing on things you know like there's
coaches out there yeah that's the fun part for me whistle
and everything too i can't wait to drain them dry oh it's
not going well that's not what i said that is i like how
we're playing no tanks here i like you guys i like him
you're never gonna
no okay okay don't worry i believe in the no tank play okay
i'm gonna go after this movie night real quick in the side
we're winning it's okay we're winning we're winning we're so
scared they're so scared i don't know why i don't know why
they're so scared awesome what's that guy doing i need okay
i'm gonna attack the backline the entire backline no i'm
gonna die first no oh my god gruelo gruelo gruelo gruelo I'm
sorry.
Oh, no.
You got a tank.
Weaser has to tank.
Not me.
Okay, oh, tank.
I'll do it.
Oh, you got blue.
We got the blue thing.
I'm blue.
What if he's blue?
What if the thing was blue?
Yeah, what if he was blue?
I'm going to die.
I might be tanking with you in a second.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
I'm a goaded blue thing.
I'm gonna go.
Okay.
Anti-Starlord?
No!
Oh my god.
They're invisible to it.
It's fine.
I almost have LL here.
They wasted.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think they have an LL here for sure.
I'm not all checked.
This is quickly.
Thank you.
Okay, can we shoot that one?
I'm not...
Oh, nice, nice.
We shot it.
We actually shot it.
I'm so proud of you guys.
I'm healing.
I cleansed it.
I still died.
I can't hit that guy Um Score girl heal me, please you can
copy and support.
I don't know what you want.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize what you're doing.
Love and peace and love.
I don't know how to heal you.
Sage, revive me We're out of here
All right But All right, I go in with my uh, are you guys
ready?
Okay Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we can get her.
All right.
Someone didn't get it because he was in...
Oh, my God.
You might need to assemble to us.
We're literally a support.
Right here, my bad.
I kind of assembled by myself.
Yeah, I was going to say, I was like, where's my kill from
my Captain America?
We got point.
I have copy.
Yeah, use it on me.
I thought I was playing Marvel.
Sorry.
I got bursted.
oh you got break i broke that wall down and b i'm gonna i'm
gonna switch yeah nice good copy outside group outside group
you want
that's the boost i needed moon night watch money i'm scared
bro oh my god take your user what the fuck phoenix just solo
altered We got this guys in this, this is our match right
now for those who are watching.
This is...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're in the finals right now, everyone.
I got a...
So short breath right now.
I do Rooter in the building.
I can't stop myself.
I can't stop Rooting!
I'm gonna groo.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I love you.
Oh, my.
The cutest shark ever.
Scrooge.
I was like, you got knocked out around one?
Yeah, they were just stronger than us, man.
Yeah, yeah, we're just chilling.
We got knocked out, but we're just chilling now.
Look at my, look at my squirrel.
Look at how cute he is.
He's got a little blue backpack.
Oh, is he really?
Oh my God, he does.
What's he got in there?
That's so cute.
I'm not.
What the hell?
Go top, right?
Oh, right.
Okay.
Go here.
I'm going to try and ante someone.
Okay.
All right, guys, I can fight here.
I'm gonna see you on the right, on the, oh, I missed.
They have an ultram, by the way.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
All right, I'm playing for today.
I don't have cards.
It's okay.
Oh, my God.
She's lost.
Lost like a fish.
Where are you going?
You don't know where you're looking?
Can we get point?
Can we move points?
Yeah, yeah, I got you.
I'm all here.
Ready?
Go, go.
We claim it.
Give me the ultron.
I want him.
Nice.
Give me him.
I am.
That's a little bit too much.
Too much.
Too excited.
Hey, I didn't pay zero dollars to not push a button.
You guys let out too much of your load, guys.
Too much.
No, no.
I'll get it back so quick.
Not me.
I saved it.
I'm okay, I'm okay, I forgot I can't crouch in this game.
Go up, go up, go up, go up, go up, go up, go up.
Yeah, sure, yeah.
We ran into this, bro.
I didn't know what that was.
I told you, I play Fortnite when I'm playing group, bro.
Holy shit, you weren't lying.
Oh, I got somebody back there.
Anti-group, anti-group.
He's stuck on the wall.
He doesn't realize the wall is in the ceiling.
He didn't see it coming.
So the Alton Gambit because he's stupid and I hate his
cards.
He's dead.
Good job.
Die!
Yeah, I got a little...
Hey, little girl.
It's okay.
If you want to go have fun, you can get off my back.
Go ahead.
I'll be here.
He's one.
I'll be chilling.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I don't have cleanse here, so if you get Groot ulted, you're
fucked.
Oh, hell yeah.
This is a free ultimate down this hallway.
Okay, good.
Nice.
All right.
Groot's alone.
Yeah.
Boxes are in.
Nice.
Watch on.
There he goes.
Oh.
I got rebuilt around myself.
I'm going to use my, we used my gambit first.
And then we'll copy later.
We'll copy.
Oh, wait.
What's this guy?
What are you doing here?
Hey, get off of her.
Leave her alone.
What are you doing here?
Is this guy bothering you, princess?
Oh, my God.
This guy's bothering you.
I got you.
I'm low.
Thank you.
I heard the death ult.
I'm scared.
I need his stuff.
Extermination.
You can ult for this?
I got two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, this?
Nice.
This last fight anyway.
I'm not portal.
I don't think they're gonna portal in quickly, guys.
You don't know.
You never know.
Sometimes I do it.
I wanted to be there.
Guys, wait for me.
Don't end without me.
Please don't end without me.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, but aren't you doing an interview first?
So, no, Machas aren't starting right away, unless you guys
want to watch at the beginning.
God, Gambit's so cool.
God, he is.
He's so cool.
They're gonna nerf him next season.
There's no way.
Oh, no, no way.
He survives this one.
No, no.
Like, the current top 500 is like majority Gambit play.
it's really that makes sense it's so dumb that's crazy what
why is he so cool it's because he has a very loving wife and
he's like a house husband have you seen the picture of her
grabbing the back of his jacket and like dragging him off
and it just is manhandled there's one you know like the
motorcycle thing like she's actually like he's like the the
little spoon in them on the motorcycle oh of course he is
yeah and rose the one driving the motorcycle that's crazy
the need that.
Oh, he has his own dummy mommy.
Like he's living the life.
Can I heal this one?
Yeah.
Actually, yo, yo, healers.
Go GPS.
Okay.
So this is important.
Who are the good healers?
All right.
I got this.
I got this first time gaming.
No problem.
Oh, you got it.
Am I the okay?
We have two healers.
All right.
We got this.
I mean, you guys can run triple support.
We can always go three.
Yeah, yeah, that's the plan.
I can just go all healers.
Let me just go ahead.
Let me just hit F1 real quick.
Okay, let's see.
Each card detonates either heals or does damage.
Okay, okay, that's simple.
I can shield myself now.
This is like life changing.
Whoa.
Raise.
Okay, that's a big heal for everybody.
Oh, and it's a chain heal.
Okay, okay, okay.
Sometimes I wish we could go back.
Got me a chunk of Cronovium that says we can't.
Oh, yeah, I'm going Loki.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
All right,
here we go.
Oh, I'm ready.
So easier than screaming, guys.
I see that.
I'm good.
like not scared for my life every two seconds yeah how'd my
team go they're around okay so i i'm dying um okay um that's
not our fault we're the dps i'm trying i'm sorry i haven't
been i haven't been playing healer i haven't been playing
healer all weekend i don't go here yeah i am lagging guys
there's no png
Yeah, I know, right?
Where are they healed?
I want it to be known.
I never speak to you like this.
At first, like, come on.
Yeah, I am also.
Oh, there's heals.
Yeah, how are we going to get enabled if our supports are
not healing us?
Oh, I'm healing you guys.
Trust me.
Just look at the numbers.
I think it's like six or seven.
Healing.
I get it now.
No, I get it now.
Alton, get in it.
All right.
Oh, my God.
thinking like i'm playing gambit right now i've been playing
him so much i got there oh my god oh i got they're down two
they're down three actually i can't see anything you know
what i can't see it come here that's right i don't care i
don't care we got the point i can do this gambit's not hard
no such thing as a hard character yeah just a skill issue
yeah exactly Wait, what happened to her?
They're portaling, they're portaling.
Portaling.
Not her though.
Triple DBS.
Oh my god.
I'm so used to like, uh, I'm so used to gambit aimed.
I don't know how to play.
Oh, please break the squirrels.
Hello, Invis.
Hello.
Heavenly, I got you.
I got you.
Oh!
I don't got, I don't got you in the back line.
I'm sorry.
Oh, they have a magic now.
this deserves your attention lush there you go nice tool
nice tool look at that now that our support started healing
again okay okay
now you know how you know I'm at 2k what you were I'm giving
you the rank experience six oh I might need catch up oh
thank you i'm so scared nice i'm going for the fantastic
yeah there's a squirrel up there she's assaulting me looking
at a tree i'm at a public park
done killing you.
Whoa.
I'm finna make a name of myself.
I'm about to make a name for myself here.
I'm about to make a name for myself in this place.
No, I don't been waiting for this.
You don't know how long I've been waiting for this.
No, I've been waiting for this.
Wait, guys, there's a magic in right behind us?
Sorry.
You guys are just getting backshotted by a magic?
I think that was a little bit excessive.
Uh-oh.
Um...
we're doing it I thought that was a second round I popped
all well it's okay you're MVP's so like you could do
whatever you want okay thanks guys I'm never mean to my
healers cuz I because I started playing healer and I don't
want I don't like I don't like yelling at that I'm training
your mental I'm training your I never say that to people.
I never ask.
Your mental is insane.
Oh my god.
I'm making sure you'll live past the rink.
This is boot camp.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You think what I say is bad?
Get ready to get to plat.
Okay, ma'am!
Yes, ma'am!
And then it gets worse.
The higher the rink, the worse the more toxic you are.
No, I actually feel like ever since I got, like, ever since
I started playing a diamond, like, it's, like, a lot better.
The people were worse in silver.
No, no, no, no.
worst i had was when i started diving that was where
everyone just had mics and would not learn how to both shut
up and not say bad words the higher i've gotten the the more
people are like actually like willing to play the game i
like silver a lot but like people like talking to their
parents in the background oh goodbye hello goodbye guys my
frames are dropping it feels like oh no this This map is
known as the worst map for frames.
Probably you are you guys.
Oh, guys, guys.
Yes, there's three different ones on us.
Freaking magic.
Oh, come here.
Hello.
Oh, hey, there's Captain, too.
Where?
Oh, cool.
Bye.
Watch out.
Wait, okay.
And Silver, can they give you the gamer words?
Watch out.
Yeah.
Okay, it's just the same then.
Yeah, it's the same.
Yeah.
I mean, there are many.
Whoa, I'm gonna...
We're missing a healer.
Back out, back out, please.
There's also...
They have strange out too, so good luck.
I'm sorry.
Where are your heals?
I don't know.
We're dead.
I died.
I'm scared.
We don't have to say it anymore.
She just says it herself.
We've trained her well.
That's right, support.
Apologize.
It's never, it's always your fault, remember that.
Ever since we were playing ARM, every time I don't heal her,
she hits me.
As she should.
Oh, we're supposed to go to the ARM.
go you are on a solo adventure oh wait oh i like that and
then i hit shift and right click again oh i'm free oh my god
then i hit q oh my god don't worry i am nearly i'm nearly
shooting here as much as i can um yeah you're yeah no i
can't i can't save that i'm gonna play i have my alt for the
next push there you go you do follow I do.
Oh, I can do this.
Their team's capture progress has passed the halfway point.
I have I have art.
You have all the go.
Let's go.
I didn't see you just rip it because they just used they
used Invisority and then I hit it again and then it does the
heal.
Oh, okay.
But don't get blown up though.
I thought he was just counting the I'm just extermination.
Where am I?
Where are you?
from there oh i've been asking myself that for a long time
oh i'm not gonna lie i just really don't feel i don't really
feel that safe here i'm not even oh my god it sucks because
their supports are healing their teammates but i don't know
what that feels like oh my god the shade is insane that's
true you don't because you died too fast for me to heal you
step back a little bit
you guys are in there oh shoot oh i am so healed there is a
heal where is my damage where is my damage oh my god i'm so
scared i'm so scared guys i'm so scared there's a man
respawn faster i don't understand i'm alive i got a triple
kill um i'm i can see whatever i want because i'm ace that's
true oh okay um i i swapped to cloak and dagger because like
i i have a hard time keeping track of you you too you're so
high oh yeah when you first storm you just gotta play like
like luna or cloak and dagger yeah yeah yeah i'm definitely
trying to stay a bit lower they're pointing oh yeah no no
you do not want to stay lower no go higher baby never fools
i can i can close this cloaking you you uh yeah that's crazy
but i'm alive so crazy no the sun's in my eyes at nine o
'clock at night i swear i was alive i was given but i was
alive what happened i think i i think i was legitimately
just a little bit too far from it no i left clicked i just
stopped paying attention oh oh well then oh wait was that my
fault why didn't you stop me from left clicking yeah
honestly true my bad been avoided it's okay off sports after
the first time somebody draw somebody draw her just kicking
us we're me and heavenly just gonna kick all the all the
support players just kicking us now you know the pain also
what the fuck isn't foul on support he's got a guilt he's
got experience the same thing, we mean now they're gonna
kick you too now they're gonna kick you too you what did i
do okay fine i'm playing my favorite healer i'm playing my
favorite healer there we go if we die you guys did a bad job
don't worry i have experience how can we die if we're
running triple support i have two games of experience in
healing i got this i just i'm out of practice i've been
doing something else for a while
corner i'm gonna get high ground you with me i'm trying i'm
really trying i'm really trying i'm so holding right click
as hard as i can if i landed on you guys blend them you zoo
blend up you zoo oh my god who is so low don't worry watch
out watch out oh i i got your heavenly oh they're over here
oh my god i feel so good there you go behind behind behind
spell the witch i got her i got her
okay that guys we're doing i'm gonna make a name for myself
here what is that is that an emote yeah chatting tatum when
he's playing gambit yeah it was like yeah like a five minute
cameo and that's all everyone remembers it because of it
fucking dead cool bro it's so awesome oh this does heal you
guys i know how long i've been waiting for this i probably
should have been spamming
It's okay
Where's our res oh there it is I got there I got the killer
I don't have hers.
I need her Oh, goodbye.
I'm holding another one.
I'm holding it.
No, no, no, no, you know, it's fine.
It's okay.
We still got point Yeah, yeah, oh fuck.
Okay.
I can't clip this Did she do it?
Oh, she did it.
I did it.
Oh my gosh, she didn't do it.
I did it the fatherly.
I know, I'm just saying you did it again!
Yeah, you did it again!
I was on your side!
What do you fucking mean?
That's so awesome.
She's just trying to be supportive, man!
I can't aim.
We get strange.
It's okay, me too.
I'm so used to a gambit game that I'm having trouble
adjusting.
Watch out!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Oh, shoot!
We gotta shoot that.
We didn't get him the first.
I'm sorry, I was only holding right click.
I have my ult and I'm so ready.
Just get him.
Just get him out of sight.
Captain America over there.
The second they show up.
Let's go!
Nice.
Well, I've got him too with you.
I've got him.
I'm trying to protect you.
It's a good idea.
I ulted.
What is wrong with what is wrong with you?
Please, please.
Dude, he's on you so bad.
He is on you so bad.
Wait, cap is one.
Cap is one.
Oh, beautiful.
No, come here.
Matter of fact, I'm going to come in this guy and get you.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
That was incredible.
I don't know.
That was crazy.
We didn't know that we won that.
I think we might win with this.
We should take this.
Yeah, we should.
Yeah.
swap everything we learned to see that they're all
everything we've strategized for so it's like is that a bot
lobby for no it's quick play guys like there's actual like
no they're just babies yeah yeah okay let's i guess now we
can are you playing now uh they should have started right
yeah they should have started right technically i'm gonna
check uh they're still talking oh they're still talking
they're still okay okay all right crazy when did they start
promptly at four i think that's what i said right now
they're still starting or i guess we can play another or do
we or do we not risk it
hello where is that um where is our where is our king i'm
gonna use the bathroom real quick sorry one second okay okay
i saw that we can i see the co-stream thing on iron mouse's
channel so we all have to open up the the co-stream i guess
because it links it links the mainstream if you click the
co-streaming thing oh okay okay um okay Yeah, our game is
the second one after this because they're streaming it.
Yeah, my chat's asking about it.
They're streaming it like back to back.
They're not streaming it simultaneously.
Oh,
my gosh.
From these quick play games, I'm going to play way too
impressive on Gambit.
Join Coastream.
Yeah.
These quick play games, they're very risky because
competitive Gambit is so different from quick play Gambit.
because I know I'm better than like bronze players.
So I'm doing the dumb shit.
I am now co-streaming with them also.
I am also co-streaming, but I don't know what it does.
Oh, it just makes it so that when you click on, they click
on your channel, it links them directly to what stream
you're watching.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, that's so cool.
Yeah, so they're like, oh, what are they watching?
You're like, oh, it's Sea Dogs channel.
Shares them with like everyone.
Yeah.
Because they're like, oh this is the main broadcast.
Oh, they're starting, they're starting, they're starting.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, I'm gonna check.
We watch.
Yeah, I'm watching.
The main broadcast doesn't have it yet, because I assume
there's a delay, but they're showing what they're playing.
So if I go to her and then hit the button.
Do we just watch her?
I'm just watching what the comps are playing.
Oh, co-streaming.
How does this work?
How do we get in this?
Start coaching.
You just click it.
I don't see it.
I just clicked it.
Oh, that thing.
This thing.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I'm watching.
Hmm.
Does it show it on our streams or how does this work?
Yeah, Chad, do y'all see it?
What is it?
I think it just says who's in the stream.
In their sign.
Oh, so then I still got to pull it out and put an OBS.
Okay.
That is showing the team.
now okay i just want to make sure because i was i didn't
want it to like double up they are doing yeah for sure for
sure running okay i'm gonna look at my notes too as well i
don't know they're actually running triple support sorry
maybe they decided last minute is that a hawk eye i see yeah
they swap oh yeah they're running oh never mind yeah you're
right i knew they're gonna hell and the more they don't get
siloed
but is that hell and the more map I don't know oh wait I
wait I do know I have the I have the cheat sheet the cheat
sheet it is that's not an actual hell and the more map
the doobster someone's like siloed bad in big season 4 bro
these guys do not know how fucking broken siloed is well
She's so scary.
Sad like is...
I felt so bad because I saw Duby kept asking to run scrims
and we were like busy and I was like, I felt really bad.
I wanted to...
Yeah.
I think like Scrims... Or maybe she's trying to get Intel.
Yeah, the thing is, normally people don't scrim with the
people within the tournament because like, you know, the
Intel.
So like, in pro play, any teams just scrim EU teams.
So they don't like leak the Intel.
Or they...
i've learned a lot against like teams that didn't qualify
basically yeah i've uh i've learned a lot just uh
experiencing like scrim stuff i've never done stuff like
this it's kind of cool it's really cool it's a very foreign
world to to me i've not played pro esports esports is
awesome when you do fgc because it's not even esports it's
you and like 10 dudes in a bar playing
do you remember the one year of um twitchcon in vegas where
we went to that bar and the bar had caught on the on the big
tvs oh what i missed that no you were there you got me a
drink at that party i'm gonna tell you that everyone should
know i was not there at twitchcon no no no i was physically
i was yeah no i guess it's vegas and every shot was like
seven bucks no bro i woke up and just damn yeah no it's
pre-gaming and then there's like pre-warfare and he was he
was deep in the trenches both of them are running it hella
no more oh my god i landed and then i had the world's worst
hangover for three days crazy yeah i say we've been well i
hella for me is more of an issue than no more is yeah but we
can't we can't yeah we don't we don't have we don't have the
space for it yeah that's why it sucks that it's killing so
hard i know it's just running everyone over that's what i'm
saying yeah they need to they need to pov sk right now i
need to see because because like if you focus sk their team
can still just hit you that's the problem it's not like
everyone else doesn't know how to play she plays every hero
at a high you can't focus her either because well yam's
gonna beat you in the back of the head oh there's just not
enough bands if it was like if it was uh mr um i guess like
the tournament bands then you can because there's enough
bands because you get three bands in tournament play but
it's but we don't get three bands like we need we actually
need three bands but we don't get three bands but i think if
they went turn advanced versus because i know they're like
oh but we want them to have bro she's not missing we want
them to have fun but like um there's just so many There's
too many characters to have like ring bands in a competitive
environment.
Yeah.
I think a lot of the players in this turn will have a
limited hero pool.
Yeah.
Blur, stop fighting and run, gang.
What are you doing?
Oh, God.
The SK flank.
Yep.
That's what you guys have to be aware of.
The thing is, you have to be aware of too.
Like, she will do that because every good neighbor player
will be flanking.
They are so loud.
Okay.
watching us if we can if non-stop yeah if we can we need to
just keep our comms like as clear as possible so we can hear
when she's there if you if you know where she is just mark
it for me I will anti her and then like we just got killer
instantly like we have to just get out a turn on her yeah
because like drink some water if you haven't don't get
dehydrated and get a headache hey no I think Amelie's team
is very strong they are just because they have just because
like itself is like a hard carry i think that's insane on um
dubie's team who is the one we have to watch out for dubie's
team i would just say is blur blur blur is blur was a blur
is a fps all-rounder he's on everything yeah and also he
used to be uh top 500 i mean he still is he's predator top
500 apex and he's always been like consistently high rank
okay so like You know, it has the FPS.
The thing is, the good thing about triple support is that it
tilts DPS players because it's so hard to kill.
But Helena more allows the Namur to basically try and kill
one of the supports that we just have.
Also, are they lagging?
Do you see her pain?
Yeah, yeah.
It's lagging.
Yeah.
They're lagging.
The packet loss, man.
Are they, are, is like, are their POVs lagging too, or is
just the spectator?
I'm not sure.
I think it's a few of these.
Yeah, I don't have the...
We've been having...
The Cloudflare, like, down thing has been really impacting,
like, our practices and stuff as well.
Oh.
Oh, they're lagging, too.
They should pause it.
Pause the game if they're lagging, too.
Do they know that that's a thing you can do?
Eski knows it.
She knows that you can pause it.
So...
just she might not need it i'm genuinely scared of sk like
yeah that's why we have to get sidlock out dude she's gonna
clip farm us no no no no it's fine we just get rid of we as
soon as we turn like if she flanks she's she's fucked
because we all just turn on her as long as we all turn on
her we're fine okay and then also we can lose if she has a
health bar it can hit z Yeah.
Like all we have to do is turn on her.
It's not humanly possible.
Well, she's built different.
So so are we.
So scary.
The power of friendship.
Listen, you might not be able to out mechanic her, but you
can out skill her with your team.
Yeah, because it's a team game.
It's a power of friendship.
It's okay.
We have a distraction.
Make it a 5v6.
Remember that, guys.
Right.
You're right.
We can make it a 5v6 easily.
Okay.
Duby's team banned Hawkeye and Seiloc.
And then.
Yeah, I don't know why the Hawkeye.
Banned Daredevil and Jeff.
I think they banned Seiloc to target.
They tried to target.
As came.
It's not worth it.
She's going to play something else and whoop your ass
anyways.
No, no.
Seiloc bad is worth it.
It is worth it.
Yes, I understand that.
But the Hawkeye, I don't understand why they banned Hawkeye.
Because they know that Heavenly Seer.
Yeah, they knew I was watching.
That was a, that was for me.
Oh my god, the solo ulti was insane.
But look, look right now.
She's throwing everything she's got at them.
No one has died on the enemy team.
Yeah, because triple support is literally triple support.
But as I'm saying, you can still out.
Yeah, Hunter's her skin.
Also, yeah, I'm going to type something in chat that, like,
type something in chat real quick.
Where's the thing?
There's so much ash on screen.
There's so much ash.
I really like this skin, actually.
Oh, interesting.
Oh, y'all got to make that breakable.
Yeah, you see.
That's got to be.
That was heartbreaking to see just now.
Like, look at the what I typed in chat.
Okay, give me a second.
Oh.
Yeah, so this falls apart.
I was watching this game in 480.
Like, their comp instantly falls apart.
If we just do that.
Not Ruhoto.
naruhoto naruhoto wattashua
okay blur let's see it come on oh and that's overtime oh my
god oh my god that's my boy
If they run Bucky, we have to swap off Loki.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
That was great.
I'll switch to Invis.
Yeah, you guys have to swap between the two.
I can film.
Okay.
Cam, I will be right back.
Yeah.
All good.
Um.
Oh my gosh.
Not to add a delay for your upcoming match.
Surprise SK didn't swap.
lot lucky i just think sk is just really strong on the more
right now with the hell yeah with the hella because she's
really strong with the hella and then i also just think
she's such a like all rounder capable player like she's very
confident her team up enables sk with that added anti-heel
like she could just burst anyone she wants yeah and
they're like make sure to go to the bathroom before you're
before we start your game yeah i'm gonna use the restroom my
favorite back guys oh it's almost over it's almost our turn
no they have to do this yeah it's only one more round one
more round is like maybe 10 minutes i'm gonna pee that's not
good yeah no no no no go ahead sorry sorry sorry that wasn't
for you i was just i thought it was gonna go longer all
right i'm just looking up what we have to ban here oh we're
getting sure to his team here i think i think we just i
think we just let you ban and like uh not complicate it with
yeah yeah i just need to not on an angela map oh yeah let me
see what they're playing on attack defense yep they're doing
namor again okay lucky Punisher blur is nasty the score no
yeah it's just like you know like it's just a shooter yeah
yeah it's like literally a wingman it's zero and two right
now or you mean like the the scoreboard yeah no man
like learn knows the moment holy shit he just needs to
target and yanners he's like he's confident that he is a
better player than yanners because he's been playing fps for
his entire life yeah and then the moment you know you got
they got a pick and then it's just over I played apex
against him once he ran my shit and I was like alright I get
it I get it man that's crazy some of you sorry just built
differently
um I hope we're not the back-to-back match.
I hope.
One of us has to be the back-to-back match.
What does that mean?
It means like after our game, we have to play another game
with someone.
Oh my god.
But it's either us or Chido that has to do it.
That's the thing.
Dude, he's nasty.
Did you see that shit?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
What happened?
Did Blur like...
He just got a Penta.
That's just...
bucky up that's why like if we know they have a bucky up we
have to save a support out for it we can't like we gotta
like hold it for sure yeah we gotta coordinate the um the
supportals we need to know you guys should figure out who's
going first and who's holding okay okay i need to look at
mine all right oh yeah i need to let me copy my notes here
so whenever we need to ban hella anymore and whenever we
need to ban angela actually okay okay yeah i don't know if i
should waste a banner angela but grut we'll see this depends
on the map yeah i am grut okay well oh you're doing it again
oh it's so nice wait i think i literally i hate it so much i
They just don't have a support alt for it.
They literally don't.
They're running all...
They had a duby alt for it.
They had a cloak and dagger, but I think she might be dead.
No, no, I meant the blurs alt.
They literally don't have...
They just don't save alts for Bucky.
Oh.
Yeah, I...
Amma's team is just an invis and a gambit.
Yeah, they ran double support.
They didn't run triple support.
If they ran triple support, I think...
held the triple no yeah full full respect blur is insane
he's just correct he's just very yeah this is actually crazy
i thought like i honestly thought that sk's team was going
to win this so this is very putting up a very significant
fight by just blur yeah wow he really locked in at the last
second holy i'm back oh my god wow what did i say gang They
can bleed.
Even gods can bleed.
They can bleed.
I told you.
Ranked intimidation should never get to your head.
You know what?
You're so right.
I'll never get you again.
We change our bands then.
Okay.
The thing is, do you want to Okay, I'll type it.
I'll type it here.
Okay, okay.
Blur and lock the heck in.
It was so scary.
I need a great counselor.
I can beat Blur's ass myself.
Do we know who we...
Okay.
Make sure you don't show the password for the room.
Yeah, I switched scenes just now.
Okay, I'm a...
How do we get into this?
Also, also, also, her losing might filter.
How do we get into this room?
You have to look out of the room name.
There's instructions in the Discord.
Yeah, I've swapped scenes too.
or not swap scenes i hide where are you leave leave the
lobby if you leave my lobby you can go in and find it the
instructions are yeah you leave the lobby and then you'll be
able to find the custom custom game yeah yeah custom game
and then type the uh the map name the name let me close that
okay what they haven't made it yet it I don't see it yeah
I'm in it oh wait I'm in it oh you invite us oh I see it I
don't see it I can't see it it's in tournament room oh okay
I was in casual room I invited just everyone but I don't
have it heavenly I invited I invited okay I'm gonna check
the map what they're playing on can i show this wabi or no
yeah you can you can yeah sorry i would i hope i definitely
hope that didn't just dq us for that but i went into bruce
chat like that's my boy well we're not we didn't play
against him it should be fine yeah it's fine yeah i guess it
should be fine let me okay oh god all right damn isa is like
that what okay isa are we missing what are we I don't go
here!
I don't go here!
Let me out!
How do I leave?
Join the coach section.
And then wait for them to swap.
And then, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Well, she's not swapping.
Okay, now, and then click it.
And click join.
On showkeepers.
There you go.
Lonely, lonely.
do you guys listen to music while you play or do you play in
silence i would be listening i don't i can't i need to focus
yeah i used to but not i listen to mri music i am ready no
the music helps me focus the mario's music yeah oh i like
feel like i look you need it i need to enter my flow state
because like i can it's just i gotta actually i might hold
on You know what?
No, because listening to music makes me stupid.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know what?
You're right.
Because then the beat drops and it's like, I gotta all- I
gotta kill somebody now!
Let's do it.
That's not an actual map.
What's true?
Do you think you want to be today?
Okay, so...
Make way for the King of Tees.
Do our usual.
We'll do...
We'll do Iron Fist comp.
Got it.
all right and then i banned bucky who's been just let her
just let doki ban so we don't oh it's not doing the thing
we're okay we are escorting so this is you guys want to ban
silo or penny um i feel like penny is a pretty good at
holding so maybe yeah this is a disc like a convoy so they
They took your, they took Gambit.
That's fine.
Then we have our- So what are we running?
We're running Mr. Fantastic.
You want Penny?
Ban Penny then?
Yeah.
Can someone press Penny for me?
I got it.
If we're running Mr. Fantastic, do you want me to play tank
or do you want me to play DPS?
What did we do?
I mean, look at the back what we do.
Great.
Okay.
It is Magneto, Emma, Fantastic.
And then- Oh, I bought a scan for this.
They fell for it.
They fell for it!
I have a new skin today!
Life energy is a powerful weapon.
And then who was the third supporter?
It was Invis or Luna?
Okay.
Can you hear us now?
Yeah, I can, but...
Yeah, I like that.
I think Invis is better though, isn't it?
I mean, Balila can't hear us or something.
Oh, it can.
Yeah, I can request pause.
pause please oh rtc connecting god the server needs change
discord not working for our team
we gotta i don't we can't change the server someone one of
the admins would answer uh i would just reload this screen i
can't initiate pause pause pause please i'll do like at he
at okay at alex pause please we don't have discord okay
there you go all right
of course discord fails on our my friend saying is they're
saying restart discord um oh wait you we have several
players that can't they can't list here okay um Oh, even on
Shoto's team?
No, for us.
We have several?
Oh, okay, we're fine.
Okay.
Is everyone okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How about kick you?
I'm here, I'm here.
Okay, we're good.
All right.
Let's just do our...
Yeah, let's test manager close it.
All right.
Okay, okay.
Do you want Emma or...
Is it Emma or Mag Emma?
We do Mag Emma.
Okay, got it, got it, got it.
Ready?
Oh, thank God they don't give me the other body.
Oh my God.
get the out of me when i did that okay yeah
i got a new skin check it out nice that's tough twin thank
you it's tough twin holy shit we're good twin damn okay yeah
thanks lazy for the five percent all charge idiot they're
playing really there's a name more in the back we got some
range to hit those I don't know.
I have such one.
You bubbled go ahead get in.
Go pushing up.
Can I proceed?
Mag can go.
Mag, Mag.
Mag one, back one.
putting pressure on the heel.
Got him!
Got him, go back, back, back, back, back, back, back.
Oh my God.
Hello.
I got you.
I'm coming.
My god, I'm rinsed.
Nice.
This is my one.
Focus on focus support focus support focus support look at
look at uh in viz in viz in this in this In this water mag
mag mag mag mag mag mag mag focus mag focus mag all right
hell up top i'll help her hell up here hell up here hell up
she's not gonna throw a life away she's not gonna throw a
life away nice kill nice kill nice kill nice kill nice kill
nice good take hey uh this auto this auto pushes push up
push up this auto pushes so any dps just get in her face and
starts just fucking like okay okay the auto pushes i got you
i got you pushing pushing i think i'll have a Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I'm talking about you right now.
You just use it for defensive?
We use mine for aggressive.
I was fine.
Back up.
I'll use it.
They use it.
I think they switched to the Punisher.
There's Punisher now.
They have an Emma now.
Did they always have an Emma?
Will T for Punisher?
No, no, no.
Okay.
I have all set.
We're going to go in the moment I have all.
Okay.
Ready?
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Push, push, push, push, push.
Come on, Nimbus.
Nimbus, nice, nice, nice.
This one is fine.
It's fine.
All you can match this.
I can't see you.
Okay, I don't know, match, go match, go match, go match.
Can I get boost?
Can I get damage boost?
Damage boost, please.
They ate me.
They have a revive beacon.
Where's she taking me?
Where are we going?
Toma doesn't know where she's going.
Toma?
Keep aggressive.
Any heals?
I need heals.
I need healing.
Sorry, son.
You're fine.
You're fine, you're fine, you guys.
I'm hitting the rocket alt.
Rock it all down.
We have no support all up here.
Back out camp.
Kite it.
Back up.
Oh, we're gonna lose her.
No, they don't know.
They don't know.
I can ult him.
Oh my days.
They didn't even see you.
That's big.
He's dead.
I'm so sorry.
She's so nice.
I got her.
3 on card 3 on card 3 on card 3 on card push that shit in no
no it's good push that whole thing in they're not they're
not portal that's such a fire i don't see a string i told
you i'm hiding
the confidence holy okay i'm gonna i'm kim philadelphia my
arms are my hands are shaking right now so why are you just
stop me too bro i got stuck here you guys back up back up
fine thanks push up a little bit we have i got damage for
you i'm not here yet one second it's fine it's fine we're
just giving space i have all soon and then the moment i oh
we go in ready three two one go go go push up push up push
up i'm on the punish here i'm also on puttisher putt i'm
going back i'm going back line i'm going back line i'm
looking i'm gonna go in viz in viz behind behind behind
they're down a healer though they're down to healer coming
coming back i'm going back it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine just play play safe we're oh play safe okay oh
we're down a healer oh we're down a healer all about this
Back up, back it up.
Cite this, kite this.
Oh, she shot me!
Oh, this is again.
Sure, Invis, Invis, Invis.
Spread.
Honestly, if we're gonna punish her.
Okay, oh yeah, save, punish her.
She missed, she missed!
Oh, nice, then!
You should copy me, copy me.
Use it.
And then we press.
I'm kicking you in a bag.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go.
No, Show is gonna have all.
Show is gonna have all.
Damage, man!
Got you, I got you, I got you.
You missed, he missed.
Mag one.
Mag one, one.
Invis, Invis, invis.
Invis, please.
Yep, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff,
Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff.
Push card, please.
Push card, push.
Push card.
Three on card.
Okay.
Come back.
I have Involve.
Nice.
Oh, that's so clean.
Good job.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my goodness.
this is all right so for this uh we can run the same comp
here um i would did they run mag i wasn't paying attention
yeah they ran okay so i was just mad he's only looking
forward he's not turning around bubbling anybody so okay so
because i'm wondering because we could run cloak for this um
but it's working on because we do have mr fantastic so i
have to stay on uh the stay on mantis here it's fine this is
it works as long as it works we can see yes i think this
works yeah we got this what is that what am i hearing
sounds a little bit my hands are like shaking yeah no me too
i'm literally i can't hit anything
i took i took my adderall today and it's it's maybe working
against me right now
i've passed the flow state i've entered the shaking state oh
come back down that's insane oh my god i hope we're not next
after this game i want chill yeah i want to pee oh just be
like oh we can't play next we have to pee we gotta pee we
all have to pee no way yeah we all have to pee um that's a
crazy right click bro where do i where do i i don't know it
just felt right to hit the laser in the head with a rock the
homed rock give me that crystal rock nice nice oh nice skill
nice skill nice one down i'm pushing up sort of forward not
too far not too far not too far not too far not too far they
just want us to be closer i got you can chill a little bit
here thank you thank you thank you just give me that crystal
his walls to be i'm like i got my i pushed him his walls
nice pool nice pool there it is you're Let me just leave
that guy behind Groo.
Yeah, back out.
Back out back out a little bit.
Wait can we get one?
We can get one.
You pull the man.
Go back on back on!
Okay, you don't have to be in that.
You don't have to be in it.
Lesu's pushed up pretty far out.
Watch out for Mantis ult.
I will here.
Go go go look.
Push this, push this, nice.
They're down one, they're down one.
But you can just kill them all.
Just kill them all.
Yeah, push on the healers.
All three healers.
All two healers, one of them just ran away.
All one healer.
We get back, we don't have the, oh actually we, yeah, back
out, back out, back out, back out, back out.
Back out, back out, back out.
All right, for this we can aggress again, and you copy me
and then we go in again, we do the same thing.
But if they punish you all, we have to put the, we have to
use the...
I'll hit Q immediately, it'll be a double knife.
Invizzle T?
Yeah, I'm standing for punish, right?
We have mag gold, we have mag gold too.
Yeah, yeah, that's true.
Copy me one over, copy me one over.
And then we can push this.
Alright, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Do the same thing!
Can I get damage boost please?
Damage boost please?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Damage boost?
We are undefeatable!
You still safe so far?
Start backing up!
She's 100% off!
Emma wants to off!
Back up, start backing up!
You see your bubble?
Yeah, yeah, she wants to off.
Thank you very badly.
I just wanted to put a shield down for Koala.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
I have Involn.
How's he holding all?
Is he holding all for me to hold my own?
All right, there it is.
Hey, I'm kiting.
I'm kiting it.
Anybody caught in it?
No, no, no.
We're all fine.
I'm going to hold them on the backside.
I'm going to ult them on the backside.
Nice, nice, nice.
Help on my whole body.
Help her, heinous.
I can't bubble.
I got two.
I mean, I got Envis.
I got lasers by herself.
They killed me.
Slip her.
I'm my own.
Oh, he's not.
I'm doing last one.
Last one.
Maybe you can't exchange if you get a strange portal.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I almost have all here.
I got it.
We have to move up though.
We have to move up pretty far.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
There it is here.
They popped.
Hit the portal.
Fucking lost them.
We're coming.
Hold on.
Damn.
We're here.
I couldn't get to the invisible woman.
Funny, funny.
I'm gonna go in this rocket.
I'm dead.
That's why I'm dead.
That's why.
Oh The portal Oh the portal We made it I'm going back It's
alright, it's alright, swap back to your comp Swap back to
your comp We lost us back off and swap off Press G and I
have copy I have copy Just back up fully, back up fully
they're gonna start running at us Back up fully And we like
to our spawn We just hold them again Yeah to our spawn, back
up to your spawn So on, they're gonna push us here.
Let's break this wall if you can.
Yeah, you can.
Let me know.
We're not all here.
Just wait, just wait.
We're not pushed up.
I'm here!
Just use this, copy me, and then we'll aggress again.
Let me know when.
Okay.
Copy now, copy now, copy now.
You're all here, they're all here.
Copy?
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
It's okay, it's okay.
We're fine.
We're okay.
She backed up anyway for some reason.
I think there's someone above.
Mantis is above.
I got you.
Damage boosting you.
Mag low.
Lazu's almost one.
Can I get another damage boost?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You see you got a bubble.
Take it in.
Nice pushback.
Got it.
Got Shoto.
Nice pushback.
Mag one.
Nice.
Push them.
I got them.
that one go just let her play oh my god no no no no
survivors not allowed this is marvel rivals It's not
friendship, Rylos.
Marvel, bro.
We made business.
You're in business?
We got a kite.
Oh, never mind, never mind.
Nice, nice, nice!
Cheetah, nice, nice, nice.
We got it, we got it, we got it, we got it, we got it.
They only have Mantis.
Mantis is one.
Back up, back up.
How far?
Help Isa, help Isa.
Back up, back up.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Three two one!
Go!
Push up!
That shotgun out of my ass!
I got their two supports!
Show go!
I'm looking, missus!
I'm looking, I'm looking, taxes.
I got biblios.
Rocket's in the back.
Toma's low.
Lazzy's almost dead.
Lazzy is dead.
That's it.
Push him in a spawn.
Back up!
Back up now.
Go.
Back up, back up here.
Back up here.
Save him, save him.
Save him.
Just absolutely back up.
Can we get shielded the one behind you.
No, we're okay.
We're all okay.
I have copy.
Yeah, we can use this to aggress this in three.
Ready?
Copy copy copy copy copy copy copy this Okay.
Oh, that's nice.
He doesn't see you.
He doesn't see you heavenly.
Hey, so don't see me for some reason.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I got you.
I got you.
You're done.
You're focusing me.
Backing out.
Swirp.
Nice.
It was dead.
Oh, we're so good.
We're so good.
Everyone is so good.
Oh, my God.
Gee, geez.
We're not last.
We can't be last.
One of many.
Guys, we can't be last.
That's the best part.
You're right.
Go, believe it.
Yes.
does that feel good seeing your name on the winner screen
yeah oh i'm like i'm nervous i have to pee again i gotta pee
too my hands are shaking oh me too don't worry my hands are
shaking too can't be last let's fucking go can we pee now
yeah i'm peeing too bathroom breaks everyone
competitions that adrenaline good amazing are we can we use
the breast room real quick everybody got up oh you're good
dokey are you did you already get up oh no i'm still here
okay no bathroom no no you guys are good uh we're gonna go
to i think a quick break uh okay it's gonna be show to
anomaly next oh thank god yeah yeah you're good you're good
uh dokey can you join um our mouse and monkey uh main
channel right now channel for us like for an interview just
real quick oh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't know why
captain all right time to go all right i don't know what to
say oh my god okay i want to watch i want to watch the
interview if you don't want to do it i'll do this yeah no no
it's fine that's my side yeah yeah character she touches
it's just like insane oh hello hello am i supposed be here
now i don't know um whoa okay i was very surprised i'm very
scared and nervous no all everyone's hands were shaking
during the games like i mean if you were shaking and didn't
show at all really okay i thought my aim was like all over
the place there but i'm very proud of my team need to be
nerfed oh my goodness no no no i they already took gambit
away from me they're I was so sad.
I was like, oh my God, I'm scared.
We can correct this gambit.
I want to see it so bad.
Please don't ban gambit.
Yeah, guys, please don't ban gambit.
So I couldn't play gambit.
She's not that good on gambit.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
I had the least amount of practice on gambit.
So don't ban gambit.
Oh my God.
Obviously, going into that game, it was a great go.
What was your kind of team strategy going into that?
Did you have, did you study your opponent?
Yeah, no, we did.
We actually, I like looked through every team, like what
they played the last two days so like you know like usually
what they're meaning is not actually what they're playing in
a competitive environment so i just looked at their matches
and be like oh they've been playing this comp they've been
playing that comp so or like they only invested all their
time playing on this hero so we knew exactly what to ban
because like target banning is a strat so like if we get rid
of like what they're practicing on the enemy team yeah so So
I know Shoto is a Bucky player, like a good Bucky player.
So because he was on my team for the last VTuber rivals and
he was a really good Bucky player the last time we were in a
team together.
So I remember that.
And I was like, okay, we got to get Bucky out.
So that was basically our strat.
I also saw that you were just running in first.
Your tanks are behind you.
Were you just trying to be a good leader?
What was going on there?
It's because like when you Mantisalt, like you get like
insane speed boost.
we're just like mock seven into the support backline because
like they can't do anything because if you have like a
mantis running straight at you what the do you do you know
so it was like watching a freight train yeah yeah because
like my shadow was just to go straight to the support like
and then kill one of their supports because that's like
literally how you play mantis and when you all all right
well well your next game is going to be against team uh team
doobie yeah you have any uh any any strategies or is it all
close to the chest secret you can't tell us oh i can't yeah
no no we can't remove that yeah we actually have like watch
the game oh yeah yeah i'm glad we could rest because like we
are all like so jittery too so we're like we can calm down
for this next game and then go into the next one uh but i
know we had like notes and stuff too being like okay this
this comp will we have to play this comp and this map will
play this comp and stuff like that so oh wow so it's yeah i
think this is what's fun for me a little planning going on
it's just that's what's fun for me i love competitiveness
because i've watch esports stuff like I watch pro play like
I even went to the land in Guangzhou so I love competitive
in general like I love esports and I love strategizing and
stuff so that's what makes it fun for me like I mean it was
it was very apparent watching the gameplay it seemed like
you have a great time yeah yeah I'm glad my team is very
happy with their first they were so nervous going in so now
they're all like adrenaline excitement everything um they
practice so so hard too so i'm just happy that they're going
there they're just happy we're not last like we can't be
last that's what we're so happy about like i don't think
thank you thank you yeah thank you again for hosting yeah
good luck it's been it's yeah i've been so nervous so but
i'm having a blast right now but thank you guys yeah it's
gonna go great thanks for being a part of it i think we all
really appreciate you joining that it's fun to see yeah i
think everyone knows you love this game it's pretty cool to
have you too much yeah yeah i would do like a street like
i'll be playing something else and i would be like let's
talk about marvel rivals for 30 minutes before we start the
game so so they're used to it fair enough well good luck and
uh have a good rest um and uh yeah i guess you'll watch the
game and see what your opponents are up to yeah thank you
again thank you i'm so excited all right bye bye guys bye
bye
Oh my god, I'm so, I'm like disassociating.
I did the interview and I was like, I'm disassociated now.
Like, yeah, I was just like, I just did that.
I just, I need a, well, okay, I got, I'm gonna, I'm gonna
use the bathroom.
I'm gonna join back in VC and then use the bathroom.
hello i'm back two teams will be 3-0 and then the rest of
teams will be whatever's left over hey oh okay okay that's
like the optimal is two teams at 3-0 i see i see you all
right hey i'm back i'm also i gotta use the bathroom now so
i'll be right back okay how long is the break probably like
uh five minutes because the timer just hit four and i looked
away for a second
i'm on tick tock that's the move that's the move bro i
respect it it's like being in the gym you know in between
sets you gotta you gotta rest because if you don't rest for
sure like you can go back to practice but what are you
really gonna practice on bots you know let's just i'm just
doing breathing exercises i'm too nervous gotta keep you so
calm i get you oh do we leave the lobby i mean i left i
didn't know if i was supposed to or not i just felt right
okay I'm back.
Y'all ever heard of Nurtz?
I'll come back.
Yes.
I know you're like crazy into Nurtz.
It helps in between matches.
A couple of Nurtz matches.
Dude, I got my fidget spinner.
What is Nurtz is competitive solitaire.
Is this thing on?
Yeah.
I'm not sure what that is.
I don't even know how to play solitaire.
You just lost me.
I don't know what solitaire is.
Solitaire is the card game where you got to take the cards
and make sure they match.
It's the stacking one, right?
together i don't know how to play that when i played when i
played belatro i made it into go fish i was getting doubles
yeah i'll meet it right now in the spirit i need it i need
to calm down my heart is being so fast right now guys so
maybe i should i'll be back i'm listening to oh my god skins
i can buy with my code oh Oh, my God, I'm so...
I think, I honestly think that new skin that I got just, you
know, it gassed me the hell up.
I was talking to my chat before the game and I was like, do
I buy this new skin?
Do I buy this new skin?
Should I buy this new skin?
I'm going to buy it.
No, for real.
I want the Phoenix Amma skin, but it's gone forever.
Oh, is it actually?
Was it from a battle pass?
Yeah.
Sorry, you guys.
I'm like, I need to calm down.
I need to calm down after that.
My adrenaline was a lot.
I like this one.
hate this new namorskin his fingers are disgusting yeah that
i don't know it's horrendous it makes me so scared it looks
like when carrots have gone old and they're kind of wiggly
it makes me gag a little bit yeah i don't like it yeah okay
buying scarlet witch bundle oh my god blue thing is real
wait you get a battle pass for free this is awesome what's
in the battle pass uh a ton of skins but blue thing
specifically you did it great yeah i was so worried to get
last so i'm so happy we didn't get last i'm watching the
animation with it i was so nervous about getting destroyed
because so this for the Angela skin.
I don't even really plan on playing Angela, but I just want
this.
Everyone was practicing the furry one.
Yes, so much.
That was your best skin, actually.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
I was so nervous.
And I was like, oh my God, I hope this Adam Waller skin is
also really funny.
I'm just happy.
I'm so happy.
I want that skin so bad.
Like, he probably doesn't have a cape.
No, you guys don't understand.
They got rid of so much.
Everyone was practicing so much.
like the other three teams they were all they were all
playing since morning tonight and then yesterday we only had
our two hours yeah that's all we had as a team together
that's all we had and then we had another two hours trim
today and so i was so nervous and it didn't help that i
enduring stream battlefield it it did not help because i was
like okay i'm gonna join i'll like i'll play with them like
after after the after the the um the endurance room because
it's not going to be that long but it took so long it's like
so long how we screamed against a manager team so we
screamed against like people actually uh who manages uh all
the protein like majority of pro teams in rivals so they
know all the strats and they know all the strats and like
what pro players play and how to counter and everything
because they have to manage the teams and a lot of them are
like decent players too so um interesting um so we asked
them to play specific comps that we know that other teams
are playing around 3 wait um so we asked them to play
specific comps that we know what other teams are playing so
we could practice against them and also doing bands that
they might do at us so but then we only had yeah i don't
think that was right three hours of that so it's not like we
should play against so like that was like how we strategize
the the screen setting um because we're not leaking strats
but they can replicate everybody all the captains have fun
names to say um huge shout out to to super gomez for also
like helping out with coaching and giving me like ideas on
like because like you know i don't know everything about pro
play but Like, you know, he does.
And he also knows the managers too.
So I asked him if he could set up a scrim.
Like if he could ask the managers, his manager to set up a
scrim for me.
And then his manager was like, bro, I could, we'll just do a
manager.
Well, bro, you know what?
All us managers, we want to play this game anyway today.
So like, bro.
And then like all the managers got together and like
scrimmed us.
So that's how we did it.
Yeah.
yeah and he also like helped coach heavenly he gave like he
gave coaching tips to heavenly and ball to so about to so
like because you know about about Lizard one of our DPS
players so uh he also coached uh heavenly and ball on like
what to do I coach the support players and then he did the
code the tank welcome back no no no we're watching we do not
oh are they starting oh no they've got the lobby ready okay
time to see what they'll say
oh wait is to mother new player what yeah is that why you
guys didn't want me to kill her you put her in a house you
tortured her yeah i saw that she's unranked yeah i saw she's
unranked so i was like oh okay that makes sense why you guys
are like don't leave her you can't leave her no no survivors
no witnesses because we stagger her so they have to wait
longer for the entire team to get together dude i know she
felt the fear of god in that moment what do i do no mercy
who do you who do you guys think will come out on top in
this match i'm a seam hundred percent i think so too i'm a
steam lover pickums do uh do kill points for it gamba gamba
mods can we set up pickums because i already saw the lazu
isn't focusing like anything he's just like trying to kill
the other tank lazu is uh out of position quite a lot yeah
they're putting all the they're putting all the work on but
you're banning yeah one of the healers is brand new to the
game they're all banning bucky did you see that oh it's
because i said it i because i said the bucky thing and now
yeah i said it just put a crazy target i was like yeah yeah
so they i made every team target bad showed now you put a
big fat target on his back and said hey kick this guy that's
so insane bro i bet he's molding right now he's actually
losing it oh they're wasting a band they actually should
have banned jeff mantis they should have been manta because
nobody on nobody on showedo's team plays is gonna play yeah
i guess they saw what i did on manta's so they're like oh
they're about to they're about to feel some you think
they're gonna try to implement that when we like fight
they're gonna i think you're gonna do well we're not banning
gambit that's the thing they have to waste their both bands
on gambit and mantis if you can feel me telepathically
talking to you switch to strange it will help you a little
bit more man just put the wall up stop stop helping the
enemies that's a magneto lock in alright good luck man
the thing is we have like we have like other cops to play
it's okay that's that's why we came up with other cops It's
like when you thought about what they would get rid of.
Yeah, yeah.
We probably shouldn't talk about it, but we have other
comps.
Yeah, we're going to let you get them.
If anyone's watching our stream, we do have other comps
that...
If you plan on snitching, no we don't.
No, we don't.
So like, target batting me ain't going to help you because
we have other comps.
Yeah.
Just get in there and have fun, guys.
Oh, God, Omelie has the triple support.
No one's dying.
yay triple support oh my god oh boy no it's oh i mean triple
support is the strongest comp i guess someone died wait who
died oh wait oh wait who are you guys watching uh the
mainstream the dokey and connor one wait we're sorry the
iron god revived what the fuck mine is like behind okay
maybe iron mouse just noticed that amma's team has all three
of the blonde women yeah one iron mouse might be like it's
white girl wednesday it's white girl wednesday we rocked
snowbody friday let's go oh god oh god damn wait yo shoto
damn what can happen to you again man he's he's got a he's
got something to prove this around he's uh whipping out the
no more he's locking in yeah i love no more no more so fun
damn i know it really feels like just go ahead i think this
was one of the namor maps no this is an angela map also wait
i got some i got another scene for you guys look at chat oh
okay okay cool
what is happening yo oh they never mind they swapped for a
portal
wait wait chodo's team wait Hey, Chodo's team doing stuff.
They're hella just locked in and started clicking everyone's
head.
Kyumi?
Kyumi's executing people.
I see her like all over the kill cam.
Yeah, the thing is like we are positioning.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, they're running double support.
So she couldn't do anything against us because we were
triple.
Like we were literally...
She like hit us and then we just heal each other up
instantly.
ask it was insane someone check her computer bro do you
remember that clip of the girl who was cheating and sea ice
and she's like tell her what did you put on my computer
oh my god uh who put that on my computer
my god the track tracking is insane.
Yeah, it's really interesting watching like really great
players.
Let me reload my thoughts.
Who the fuck is Cream Lord?
Is that Aethel?
That's Aethel.
Yeah.
That's awkward.
Look, she didn't have mercy.
Oh no!
To my run!
That's so much.
Oh, no.
She was so young.
Look, SK didn't have mercy, so why should I have mercy?
You were first, you said the tone.
Yeah, she watched you do that when I read I'm doing that
too.
That's true.
It is what it is.
Oh.
That was a nasty alt.
that was a nasty old he disrupted them a lot he's screaming
on him i know he's going at it i'm gonna look at my notes
guys he's screaming yeah we're playing doobie's team next
right okay yeah they're both they're also on break okay okay
i know what to ben okay um that shouldn't be me
i'm i'm theorizing i'm strategizing for a next
game oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh they're stabilizing do they have trip support
or what no they both were running both of them are running
two two two okay i see two two two yeah interesting Hmm.
Hmm.
I don't know.
This car.
Oh, whoops.
What the fuck is that cross here?
The cogs are turning.
Which one?
The strange?
The strange one?
That's the spread of his bullets for up close.
Oh, what the fuck?
I didn't know that.
What the heck?
Yeah, it's a really wide crosshair because he's like a
shotgun.
Like, so if you're really close, if you're in that circle,
you can still shoot and hit him if they're low.
That's like, that is a weird ass cross here.
I just...
Yo, how on earth did SK flank and dare teen die?
What the fuck happened?
Oh my god, this is crazy.
They probably noticed SK is really, she likes to gank a lot.
Mm-mm.
Okay.
Yeah, I mean, yeah, that's what I know.
Like, that's how Namor players play.
You can see Shoto doing the same thing where he just walks
in the back.
The back side.
That was a pretty OK.
Oh, oh, oh, my God.
No, no, no.
That is insane.
It's just watching a hydrogen bomb versus baby.
Oh, no, stop.
It's her first day on the job, man.
Oh, my God, bro.
hydrogen bomb versus baby is insane
I can't man
it's actually Shoto is doing like their team is doing a
great job right now because I was like bad fucky I think
when you walked up and said yeah we just banned Shoto's
bucky we just walked away with a W like now he's mad as hell
now he's like I know his neighbor is really good he helped
us win the rivals with name or two I didn't mention that I
Because his neighbor is actually surprisingly really good
Don't Don't piss off Shoto Yeah like during the VTuber
rivals Oh there he goes That was crazy Damn There he go
There he go No during the VTuber rivals There was a A pro
player Sneaked in to this VTuber rivals And then Like, Shoto
fucking diffed him.
Like, he tried to magle us, and Shoto, like, Shoto, like,
as, you know, the circle title way thing, he used this title
way thing and blocked the entire magle.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm, like, with, like, uh, we were like, reflex.
Do they got a touch?
Does that, does that kill you?
Or are you invulnerable?
No, you're invulnerable.
You're, you're literally invincible in there.
So, like, he literally saved the entire team by blocking it
with, with his, like, the title wave shit.
He said, for my country, for my team.
Yeah.
This is a clincher.
What?
Oh, this shield is nasty.
Oh, that's game.
Oh, she got him.
She got him.
That's game.
Oh, look how close it is, though.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh, my.
Oh, yeah.
Can they hold?
That shit was right at the edge.
It was literally at the tip.
That was so crazy.
What the heck?
Yo.
I think we pissed them off.
And they're like, how dare were they?
I'll take it back.
It wasn't just you.
I think that, oops.
That was nasty.
I actually like the flow of this cup a lot.
It feels like there's a lot of nice down time and then
there's up time.
You know, it's not like up, up, up, up, up.
I have the volume at full minus.
Why is it full?
Oh, I don't.
Oh, no, no, no, get off the Punisher.
Bro, you're doing so good.
The boy, what you doing, bro?
This is such a good hold for Namur.
That's such a good hold for Namur as well.
Yeah, this was, this is a good, oh, they're, because they
want to run triple support, triple sup.
They wanted to sustain.
I'm surprised they're not running three, three, then.
Well, there's no mag, so I guess this Punisher won't be,
like, punished as much.
like Punisher is good on this map too but like his name more
was so clean yeah
I'm sorry I don't see anyone playing Angela I don't know if
we should be on here um it's not um it was it was Shoto's
team it was Shoto's team that had the Angela there team the
team chat in the discord let me see oh oh
that's not cute that's cute as her the art is so nice um i
should be the one joining in the stomping uh i am not a
victim yeah i am not a victim yeah i'm part of the problem
and she proud of it yeah a problem and proud that's right i
can't believe the cart doesn't block los no it's just not
tall enough they're just giving up so much space they are
they're scared without without like losing anybody they they
should they should have pushed up a bit more like this is
way too much space that they gave up no strange isn't even
on the point he's like completely off in wonderland by
himself yo go down mid man so do no i asked look for
flankers he's scared he's he's oh okay yeah that's why you
don't do that
what the fuck is oh i was gonna say is the is the mag okay
yo yo he took like nine spears to the chin man what the did
did us just eat the magneto oh did he just yeah yeah that's
how you do it that's so aura oh but shoto is crazy oh the
punisher that's right it's like bad my bucky bucky bad my
bucky i salt your girl i salt your earth yeah my bucky oh my
god dude he's popping off oh it's hawkaii tab hawkaii is a
very good new stopper character that's the thing because he
punishes hawkaii punishes bad positioning so as long as we
don't have bad positioning that's gonna look up to the right
there's free old charge just standing there no that's the
clones you don't get all charged off they were she was up
there oh really oh yeah I was like, um...
She was just standing there healing.
It was like, oh, that's just...
Oh.
Holy game, sense.
Don't do it.
Don't challenge her.
You don't got it like that.
Uh-oh.
I mean, they're pushing up, Zelle, for free.
Oh my god, Shoto, you're fucking wild.
I love that shotgun.
Play Gears of War, Shoto.
Let's see it.
Oh, oh, oh, no.
Oh my god, this is random.
Oh, God, this is random.
He's altered!
SK just wasted it!
no no no no she's got res too he's no he she doesn't have it
yeah and he got res too zero kills oh miss hit oh m jesus oh
my god shoto you're fucking crazy for just doing that in
front of everyone like you fall bro get high ground shoto
get high ground you're crazy they double support oh wait no
they didn't okay oh shoto's dead that's insane oh my god
caught out no that's that's an easy kill right guys oh point
guys point tomah's kind of kiting did you see that she's
going left right left right oh tomad's dead oh oh well okay
when i said that 10 seconds ago she was alive that's like
her tires she did did uh they're he ends backing out no no
they don't unless someone's got to save him no no you can
portal they could portal this oh someone's got a portal a
portal.
Armor!
What is it?
Oh my god!
Wait, they full held!
They full held!
Oh!
Wow.
They full held them!
What?
Oh my god!
Wow!
That's crazy, that's crazy.
What just happened?
They literally shut down the Namor.
That's their... That's what they need.
It's our turn.
Wait, they're gonna make armor O1 too?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
That's it.
We're all...
Okay, everyone's tied now, so...
If Amma's 0-2, there's no comeback.
No.
No, she's not 0-2.
Oh, wait, she?
Oh, yeah, she is.
Yeah, she is.
Does that mean she's out?
No, no, she has a chance to...
Oh, wait.
Yeah, she's out.
Are you sure she's going 1?
She's out.
Yeah, she's out.
Oh, my God.
I thought she was the favorite, because her team was good.
Yeah, with Eski.
Yeah, because Blur won the first one against them.
Yeah, yeah, she's out.
But she says, like, one more.
And y'all were terrified.
I am!
I respect Eski's skill.
I respect her skill.
Eski's mechanically crazy.
I know you were, but some people in here had tears in their
eyes at the thought of going okay, okay, who is some people
had tears?
okay let me and fix look at the bands again real quick okay
i got the bands okay okay all right
is it our turn now yeah yeah so they sent the they sent i
swapped i'm swapping the bands a little bit okay all right i
got a hard mob game too oh i just invite us one person can
join and then invite the rest of us oh yes invite julian
will you please invite get in so all right uh we join
remember the joining team dokeybird isa why does this keep
happening to me you're on the wrong team wait doobies yeah
doobies up there doobies on the wrong team for her own for
her own team she's swapping oh my god i saw coach you okay
thank you oh my god thank you coach thank you
Oh, man.
Well, we...
Do we know what we're doing for this one?
Yeah, yeah, I got the bands in.
Wait, why is my...
Okay, I was going to save.
My game wasn't showing up on my OBS.
I got scared.
I don't know if I can kill Blur.
You gotta for country and for team.
What happened?
For team and for country.
I killed Toma.
If I could kill Toma, you could kill Blur.
You killed Toma because you like stepping on...
That was like killing a baby.
You were just like, yeah, I love beating up babies and
stepping on ants.
it's right and what's wrong with that what's wrong with that
ain't nothing wrong with that i killed mama too a couple of
times yeah exactly you're proud of the problem but this is
my boy i don't know if i can oh bro he'll he won't hesitate
just remember he won't hesitate to do the same thing to you
yeah i know yeah yeah all right i'm ready all right the bans
figure it out okay
i'm i'm i'm just i'm interested what they're gonna ban if
they're gonna target bad me music off because it frees up
our other comps without without ban yeah i think they're
going after you yeah but it does free up our other comps so
i don't care about that
He's not my boy no more.
Oh!
That was fast.
Yeah, man.
Put the mask on.
I like him, but shit.
That's valid.
That's so valid.
I feel you.
Cut all ties for this attorney.
He's cut throat.
Yeah, you gotta switch them on to day ones once you get $5.
We're waiting for a production person for a spectator.
Oh yeah, we have...
No, we have three spectators.
We're missing.
They said they were...
They said they were waiting on another one.
There he is.
The Asian.
What a name.
Wait, that's awesome.
He... Asian and proud.
Yes, we have to get more Asian.
Asians rise up.
Yay!
Okay, let's do it.
Alright.
Why don't we just don't pick anything?
Or we'll pick one thing.
Let's all pick Jeff.
Oh yeah, let's all pick Jeff.
that's our anyone that stream sniping us that's one of the
our god comps yeah yeah all five of us one character all no
all six of us is jeff oh six jeff's six jeff yeah they can't
kill us all we have insane all right um i love he's so cute
i know he's evil but he's so cute
throw him into the ditch she spilt like a little bulldog i
got pumpkin on my head
oh oh that was that was hateful that's a crime are you just
batting all supports they may have been gambling yeah
they've been maybe they're trying to make a triple maybe
they're trying to make a triple heal comp difficult yeah
They ban Iron Fist.
I'm going to lose my mind.
No, you're literally a Jethro.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
All right, nice.
All right.
I can't stop brooding.
And then...
What do you want?
I think one play either Luna.
Luna or Cloak.
We can run Cloak because they don't have Mag.
Nothing can kill you.
Okay, okay.
Emma or Strange?
What do you guys...
Or, or we run Luna and then you can, our Iron Fist can never
die.
I love the Luna.
Me?
You want Luna?
Guys, what do I, what do I play?
We do the same, we do the same tank, tank lineup, but
instead of Mag, he's on Groot.
No, no, Isa.
Me?
Isa?
What were you running?
Emma?
Strange, stranger Emma.
Emma, Emma.
Okay, okay.
So put the Snowflake on our Iron Fist only.
that's it that's all you have to do they may run angela no
all right just put it on uh put it on our iron fist and then
he'll never theoretically you should never die so if you die
like there's nothing in the world that could save you like
okay it's real like if you died you messed up basically
nothing in this world could actually save you if you die
they have hawk eyes so position they have hot blur if that's
you i swear on everything i'm switching oh that's right
position yourself guys right i position ourselves hawkeye's
all about positions like i can start like i can start
hitting all right they're shooting my big wall they're
shooting my big walls and he's shooting the big walls any
heals we need to break this wall that's right i'm just
trying not to i'm not trying to peek too much uh anti-heal
anti uh hawkeye it is blur We're fine.
We're fine.
Get around this wall.
He's boxed.
Blur is anti.
Oh.
Oh, I'm dead.
That's fine.
Almost have coffee.
Nice.
Nice kill.
They're down.
They're dead.
Help me.
Their healers are boxed.
Take his wrist.
Oh, no.
Helper.
Oh, it's the Hawkeye.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, no, no.
That was me.
I didn't know what it was.
I shouldn't have pushed out.
Okay.
We might need a...
Chill here, chill here, chill here, chill here.
No, we can't, we can't, we can't.
Chill here, chill here.
You copy me and then...
Oh, we can.
We should have ported that, actually.
Can you contest it?
Can you touch?
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, Okay, okay, look.
Okay, wait a minute.
Oh, you copy me, copy me.
Ah, it's unlucky.
It's fine.
Just fight this.
Fight this, fight this.
Copy the enemy.
Damn baby, can't.
No ETP?
Oh, okay.
Oh no, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Just die.
We have press G, press G and return, press G.
All right.
I feel like, I feel like the Emma is like not working.
I feel like...
You want to swap?
Yeah.
I'm gonna go strange.
Yeah, because I can't protect myself.
Yeah, exactly.
I have ulti.
Doki, I'll wait for your ulti.
No, you copy, Yuzu copies me, and then we all go in with
that.
Okay, right now.
Okay.
No, no, not yet.
Not yet.
Are you all here?
Yeah, do it now.
Yes, yes, yes.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
Femi's alting, Femi's alting.
Oh, my gosh.
Where's our support?
Luna, you can all...
Got him, got him, got him.
Oh, nice thing.
Luna, you can all alt to save this fight.
They're down too.
I'm coming back.
They're boxing in.
We can kill them.
We can kill them there.
All right.
I'm coming back.
I'm coming.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
That's huge.
Outside, outside.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
They wasted ulti.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They wasted all.
Amelia.
We don't need, don't use anything.
Don't use anything.
Come back.
Well, I can kill you.
Fuck, okay.
No, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's fine.
So if they punish it, we have to luna-alt this, but we have
to kite back in that luna-alt.
Okay.
Because, okay, at first we kite back, but if he starts
pushing us aggressively, the luna-alt's, okay?
Yo, blurs up, blurs up, blurs pushed up.
Help, help, help!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's fine.
I'm backed up.
That's fine, that's fine.
They're gonna punch her all after this, so we have to kite.
Get ready to kite, get ready to kite this.
yeah get out of it.
Oh, I got killed again.
That's fine.
Should I go fantastic and safe, to be honest?
It's fine.
Re-alting.
I'm going to do the fantasy.
I think we can hold it.
I think we can hold it more.
Actually?
That's fine.
I'm coming back.
Oh, no.
We die on point.
Die on point.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Dying.
We have another fight here.
At one point.
Do you want to do fantastic?
I'll be able to get ulti really fast.
All right.
Or do you want to keep on Eifus?
I think Iron Fist is.
Okay.
We can like shred tank and then we can just start.
He's just he's just gonna be looking at us.
All right.
Start going up.
Don't get picked.
All right.
Gotta break it.
Whoever dies first has to play Strange.
I'm Strange right now.
You're a wall.
Push in, push in!
Push in!
I am Altinas!
Judge!
Never fall!
Execution!
Oh my god, he's on me.
Uh, I got walled off.
Oh no!
Okay, I'm switching to Intestor.
Yeah, yeah.
I think I'm gonna swap.
We think we need to get damage?
You gotta back out of there.
You gotta die or back out.
Oh, you're...
I don't know about damage.
Because they're able to tap us, like, a lot.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I got you.
I'm good.
I got out.
All right.
I'm like halfway to my alt again.
I'm 70% of my alt.
What the wrong?
Did they use Grudal yet?
Did they already use Grudal?
No, he did not.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna keep being, I don't have cleanse for it yet.
He's usually gonna get a cleanse.
I'm, we're five.
Are shielding.
I walled them off.
All right.
My old, my old.
I got healers, I got healers.
They have no healers.
No more alt.
Yeah, I got it, I got it.
I got Hawkeye.
We can keep pushing.
Keep pushing.
All right.
Back up.
Back up soon as well.
We'll use, use his copy.
But if they, yeah, use us, we all, we engage first.
Okay.
Do you want me to hang around and like try and get an alt
off on them?
Oh, the fucking wall came back up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ready?
Go, go.
Copy, copy, copy.
Nice.
Outside, outside.
Flores right here.
Rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket.
Rocket, rocket, rocket.
Nice, nice, nice.
I got Hawkeye, rocket.
Hawkeye, I got Hawkeye.
Hawkeye, I got Hawkeye dead.
Hawkeye, just keep going.
Keep pushing.
Careful, careful, careful, careful.
They're boxed in.
They're absolutely boxed in.
Yes!
Punish your dead, punish your dead.
They have no DPS.
They've no DPS.
They're both.
Keep both.
Get the rocket off.
I died.
I'm out.
Okay, I'm out.
I'm saving.
I'm going to save you.
Back up, back up, back up.
I have all.
Yeah.
I have to all just to save us.
All right.
They switched, Blair switched off of fucking, he's moving
right now.
We have to.
When you die, you say, you have to swap off.
Swap off Loki because he's just going to farm all top of us.
I have alt ready.
I got you.
I'm walling.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
It's fine.
It's fine, I'm walling.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
We're all in it.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, two dead, two dead, two dead.
Two dead, two dead.
Two dead.
Okay, Moonite, care Moonite, care Moonite, care Moonite.
It's fine, it's fine.
We're fine.
Moonite, can we do Moonite?
Can we Moonite, please?
I'm dead.
Oh, Moonai, Moonai, Moonai, Moonai, Moonai, Moonai, Moonai,
Moonai, I'm going back land.
I'm going back.
I got him.
Roo's locked in.
Roo, go, go, go, go.
Roo, go, go, go.
Nice, nice, nice.
You rolled me out, though.
I got scared.
My bad, bro.
It was you and him.
Stop bouncing on it, bro.
They're going to port out.
They're porting.
I have ult.
Rocket, rocket.
I got rocket.
I'm on yapping.
I got, I'm getting it.
Then he's all things and he's all things and he's all
things.
He's one.
Got him.
Use everything.
This is last fight.
Only, only.
Nice.
All right.
Good swaps.
Nice swaps.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Should I go iron fist this one because we're pushing?
I think try iron fist and if it doesn't work, we do
fantastic.
Okay.
time to switch things up i'll try emma first and then i can
go back to yeah yeah yeah we don't have oh we can go petty
on attack here whoa wait coachman said he can be in vc with
us he was told that he can be in vc with us to coach us nice
what whoa hop in
team said they want him to join us.
Hold up.
Coach, coach, coach, coach, coach, coach, coach, coach,
coach, coach.
Okay, he's in trim right now, but coach, coach, coach.
Coach, coach.
Is he going to come later?
Yeah, he's going to come later.
He said he's the cat right now.
Okay, okay.
Yay.
Oh, my God.
All right.
I'm getting hard focused by their DPR.
They're literally, like, trying to kill.
me first yeah that's crazy yeah they like i saw both of them
were trying to solo me
okay let's go
that sticker is so cute yeah yeah oh oh oh so sad man we did
not look we did not look sad you know spider-man it's fine i
that wolverine tail wolverine oh wolverine i got you guys
bastard blur i got him i got him i got him oh he got him he
got away he dashed are you ready we popped his passive right
yeah i don't know actually i didn't see it it it did pop
wolverine behind don't worry Oh, He got my ass!
Oh, he got my ass!
Oh, it's fine.
Oh, I got I webbed him.
I webbed him.
Okay, I'm...
I'm...
I aim to go moon.
Mr. Fantastic?
I don't know.
You're blocked on me, blocked on.
It's fine.
You're fine.
I guess I'll do it.
I'll do it.
I don't think so.
It's just the Penny's big number.
Disgusting conversation combination.
Are we able to, like, somehow target Penny?
We might have to go Groot instead of Penny.
Yeah, I'm going back.
I'm going back.
Yeah, go back.
All right.
The wolf is gonna like target me.
It's fine, it's fine.
Help me, help me here, help me, thank you.
Passive, passive, we pop passive.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm targeting group.
I have all here, we're gonna arrest this.
Get the big wall, break his big wall.
All right, ready?
Go, go, go, go, go!
I got Ness, I got Ness, I got Ness.
Ness, Ness, Ness.
Push up, push up, push up.
Alton five.
Get that rocket, get the rocket out if you can.
I'm going with the rocket out.
It's kind of old me or yeah, you got me.
We have all drops defensive.
That's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
They canceled my...
Wait, they used my...
Just die, just die.
They used a brute ult.
Yeah, yeah, just die here.
Just die here.
Okay, okay, die, die, die, die, die, die.
Just die.
Why are they taking...
Why are they taking forever to kill me?
Yeah, I know.
This is the slowest planned death ever.
I wasn't even Wolverine's initial target.
You were a coincidental...
like does anyone know i played moonlight does anyone know i
played moonlight no i do okay three okay blur stop it okay
he caught out that's good use it use it use it use it all
right
and I'm gonna use this after oh wait no else no more else no
more else we win this okay I'm gonna all tier if I can just
oh no oh my he threw us into the mines that was yours in the
mines yeah by the way I have We can save it.
Okay, um, heavenly.
Swap the Moon Knight right now.
Yeah, yeah.
Swap the Moon Knight.
Okay, I'm gonna use mine and we engage here.
We can go in with it.
Okay.
I'll be able to kill them.
All right, ready?
Yep.
Three, two, one, go.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
Go, go, go.
Nice.
All right, I'm going to breaking it.
I'm going for it.
Wolverine behind again.
He got me.
Oh.
Did you get anyone?
I got out.
No, no, no, no.
Okay.
Reloading.
I saw the penny.
Penny, penny, penny, penny.
Penny, penny, penny.
Nice, nice, nice.
They have no tanks.
They're racing.
I'm on focus.
Group one.
Group.
Wolverine.
I got rocket.
They're portally, portally, portally.
Restraint, strange, focus on strange.
Just strange, just strange.
Hold on, I'm putting pressure on both healers right here.
Nice, nice, nice.
One healer dead.
I'm blocking, I'm blocking, I'm body blocking.
All right, we're good.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Stay on Moon Knight, stay on Moon Knight.
They're running, okay, if they stay on Penny, stay on Moon
Knight.
Yeah, they're still on Penny, so we win this.
You need me to switch still, or I feel like I'm kidnapping.
Yeah, you're good, good, good.
Just kidnap the Grood non-stop, that's all you have to do.
Should I be pushing?
Sorry, Blur.
You're not grabbing me.
Easy, big dog.
That's fine.
One person push cart and then the rest just push up a bit.
I almost have coffee.
All right.
I see you in there, dog.
The moment we use coffee instantly, the moment we get it.
We alting?
Just to push them back?
That's nice.
Push up, bring it up.
Back up!
Back up, back up, back up, back up, back up!
Back up, back up.
Save our, save them, save them.
Come on!
I got Malte's too.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
Okay, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
They're alting?
They double support out.
I'm alting, I'm alting.
After this, I can alt.
I need help here.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I rest, I rest.
Keep engaging, keep engaging, keep engaging, keep changing.
We're up.
A little bit more old stars.
A little bit more.
I got Flurry, kill Flurry.
I've got him.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Wolverine, nice, nice.
Wolverine dead.
I'm looking to support.
Doobies by herself.
I'm looking.
Cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak.
Keep pushing, keep pushing, keep pushing.
Keep pushing.
Keep pushing up.
Three on card.
Push out.
Block it.
Back off.
All right.
We got it.
We're on storm now.
We can swap up Moon Knight.
Swap up Moon Knight.
You're on storm.
We don't need Moon Knight.
We need head scan.
Oh, wait.
Actually, uh, yeah, we need head scan for this.
This guy wants a so bad he's so in my face uh the wolverine
has all the wolverine has all so um just make sure you don't
get hit don't get close to the wolverine that's all you have
to do oh my god i didn't see the nate that's my bad we need
to get blur has to off he's one i almost have multi i almost
have multi oh i'm dead oh that's bad i wasn't gonna heal the
fuck we can get group nice nice We're not giving him.
Give him.
I've got it.
I got you.
Got you.
We're even spending.
We can push up a little bit.
We have more.
Storm-alting.
Do we have a support?
No.
It's gonna get damaged by it.
Okay, I can't...
There was nothing we could do there.
We're still fine.
We're only down one.
Fight this.
Focus on...
I'm dead.
Could we pair Gambit ulti?
I have my ult.
Back up, back up.
John, Jeff Nado.
Let's pair ultis, let's pair ultis.
Should I go, should I go uh, Strange instead?
We need to heal.
Go Strange, go Strange here.
Yeah, yeah.
Yuzu has ulti.
We have three ults.
Yeah, yeah.
Copy me here.
And then we use Takaire.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I'm shooting the...
I'm going for the ultimate.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm shooting you still.
Okay.
We're good.
It's broken.
It's.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Don't let them.
Free my beacon.
Look, look.
I got her.
Get her.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, jump, jump, jump, jump.
Somebody stay on it.
Don't worry.
I got it.
I'm all here.
Okay.
Get it.
Well, she got off it.
It's fine.
She got it.
Oh my god!
Let's go!
Oh, let's go!
Oh, I can have the penny over the point!
Yes!
Oh my god!
I'm so happy!
Holy shit.
Okay, but Lila Yes!
Oh my god!
I need a letter number.
I was losing my mind.
Those swaps are good.
Good call on all the swaps.
Yeah, that was some good ass swaps.
Oh my god.
Oh my god Jeez guys We're in the finals automatically We're
in the finals even we lose the next one doesn't matter.
We're in the finals
Oh my goodness Jesus like I feel like we're doing our team
is doing a really good job of supporting.
Yeah, yeah, and like him like just run around yeah yeah see
see we have more comps the Wolverine one wasn't even planned
oh let me ask okay oh he was like oh i heard on iML stream i
could join in but i'm not sure anymore
all right but ggs guys i'm proud of all of you i am so proud
that was some good call out yeah i'm so thankful that
heavenly is like so flexible into yeah yeah i can play
anything except for gambit apparently no he has no he has
two pages of instructions no i don't blame you i but oh my
god yuzu though my god look at your stats yuzu yes that's
our unranker here thank you oh my god yuzu was insane i feel
bad yeah like i saw you i saw you mvp like the whole game
yeah you just got one more kill more than here and then
stole it from here that's not nice That's fucked up.
Yeah, it's fucked up.
So who, wait, who plays that?
It's us?
We go against Amos.
Yeah, we go right next right away.
Yeah.
Uh.
Was I not supposed to leave?
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Can you invite me back?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
It was a JK Gomez can't join in.
That's fine.
Okay, okay.
That's good.
Yeah.
oh wait we'll win it we'll win in his honor it's okay yeah
yeah we'll win in his honor i think it's a break time right
got you well break time okay i'm gonna pee i also have to
pee all right guys for the last game to the last game yes
it's like no pressure we're in the finals automatically we
can we don't have to we it would be cool to win but you know
no pressure we should yeah yeah still try your best yeah try
our best yeah just don't know pressure i'll be right back
okay key break
what that means i'm happy my team has the free rail to know
when to swap too
yeah i'm just happy everyone did their part yeah because
like they knew what to do to swap as well because i don't
know i i don't have like all the knowledge of counter
swapping because i didn't play this season as much um well i
mean i did guys i didn't want to show it but because Wait, I
don't want...
No, actually, I can't show it because I don't want jinxed
us.
I don't want it.
You know what?
I don't care.
For a second, I don't care.
I played Rank for two days.
And then I...
Okay, wait.
In 5.2 hours.
um but it's like but it's i mostly played gambit though it
was mostly gambit too
yeah it is literally i was very fortunate that gambit is
very strong for a second i don't care i'm just i'm i was
really nervous i honestly was incredibly nervous like my
manager was like was like are you sure you want to do this
oh my god yes i'm so happy i my goal is like i hope we win a
game but look at us we won two games we have we won two
games guys i'm proud of all of us we're doing so good oh my
god i mean we're fighting too scary are we fighting dubie's
team again or wait no no churdo's team has to fight dubie's
team right after our game so our first and second is
determined by whether or not churdo's team beats dubie's
team okay okay so yeah so nervous we're not we're not the
next up then no we are we are oh oh apparently are we i
thought we are right i would think that they are because
we're next so whoever uh whoever wins the next game is our
finals oh man oh my god we already went up against everyone
then right no we have uh amalee's team after oh amalee's
team is next we are up next yeah they just haven't given
they're just on a break right now okay oh i see okay oh i'm
so
I'm okay now because I know we're in the finals and I if for
a second it's fine with me.
Never settled Doki.
Never settled.
Aim for the stars.
I know.
We got it.
We can win.
We can do it.
We have the skill.
Aim for the stars.
Oh my gosh.
Bro, I'm getting one guy.
My chat doesn't even know who's next.
Like they're like, no, it's not.
No, it guys.
It's Shona versus Scooby next.
the graphics are wrong i think oh i'm looking at match order
like if you go back in the vod you can see it um so i don't
i think it's so it was dubie versus joki next is dubie
versus shodo and then next after that is us versus ama if
we're this looks this looks right yeah because it's
whatever's on top goes first and then whatever's on bottom
goes second yeah
It's not wrong.
I just can't read.
Okay, we got a nice break again.
Duby versus Shoto next.
Oh, okay.
So we get to watch.
I can't read.
I've illustrated that so many times today.
We were playing a scream earlier and there's a button when
you pause, it says continue and then continue.
And I think, wait, no, one says confirm and one says
continue.
And I just hit continue because continue and confirm look
like the same word.
And I started the game for everyone and Heavenly was eating.
Yeah, oh yeah.
at least we can't have somebody yeah
oh i'm sorry i'm so so nervous we can just relax now we can
relax relaxing it's hard it's too hard i'm too scared it's
okay it's okay whatever happens we get at least 2.5k right
right well that's first place right I don't remember I don't
remember at what the price I don't remember um all right
rule set I don't remember I remember it was like oh we get
3.3 k whatever happens in the end oh divided by six my
monitors just died oh shit my my my rivals just crashed oh
oh no thank god run break yeah oh my god okay uh send and
close give me back my game
hey i'm back hey had a little tick tock break did uh nice my
driver is exploded they're coming back my drivers exploded
they're coming back oh no oh no that's okay we can ask them
to pause the game for like 30 no for 30 minute break and you
can drive the best by it yeah no no it's okay i've been
having like random driver crashes like i've updated to the
newest ones and it just has issues i don't know why really
oh yeah definitely never update newest drivers oh yeah if i
don't update newest drivers it happens more i've been on the
same nvidia driver since i plugged this graphics card in my
computer because when i updated it once everything fell
apart so i was like yep go back no it's actually a windows
11 issue because it's only started happening after i after i
had to swap because windows 11 sucks ass it does suck wait
none of y'all have like a microsoft sponsorship right well
not anymore i'm getting nice going guys what if what if we
be nice and we give we give sk siloed for her last game no
no thank you if you if you if you squash a first-time player
then i don't believe in this don't you guys come on we can
give her give her a chance to finally nice and ban it how
about yeah you don't want me to target ben i'm so down i'm
so down i'm so down the thing is guys saying is yeah that's
self-love you know what all right try and out ban me it's a
rank ben i i like my odds and gotcha
okay but this is our first bed and then we gotcha who who
wins the second ben we gotcha who is this that's awesome i'm
so down
no i should have terrible gotcha life but gotcha gacha gacha
gacha
gacha i'm just figuring it out about i think it'd be fun you
know what if like to see who wins the ban
so we've been against both of those teams already right yeah
yeah so yeah oh are they playing a game right yeah so
they're playing they're starting now so the thing is whoever
wins this game we're going to be playing the next and it'll
be best of three oh so amily is like out yes into you're
you're fully yeah there's no coming yeah okay okay what's
your pickums for this one which team do you think is coming
out on top honestly it's showedo's team pulled the heck
through that was crazy i i i put money on doobie's team blur
is just so nasty i'm kind of scared of him yeah blur is like
more more versatile in what he can play we said us was nasty
too but yeah happened okay maybe maybe if we say he's nasty
i think it's because like sk has been doing like flashy
plays like more so like i have to kill people like so she's
like flanking a lot but flanking is farming clips like but
flanking we're going on a tick tock but the thing is
flanking is like you know high reward uh high risk so like
everyone's been turning around on her and the moment she
dies like the whole the front line like the whole front line
collapses oh i see storm
ban interesting i
love not banning their bucky is so interesting i think
they're confident going through i mean they're running hella
namor um oh whoops i forgot to open mouse the stream i was
fucking chats were just looking at me it's gonna be like a
bucky div i can't they're staring at you the Oh, they're
going to run Bucky versus Bucky.
Oh, wait, Storm.
That's interesting.
They didn't run.
Oh, I guess they did because they were scared of Lur's
Storm.
Yeah.
Gambit Ben.
Uh.
That doobie, the skin that doobie is wearing, that cloak and
dagger skin, it reminds me of like a Sprite can.
Sprite sponsor.
All right.
We get to see his Bucky, guys.
Yeah, well, Blur's not playing Bucky.
Where's my Bucky 1v1?
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
He gets to finally play it.
The thing is, the reason why I also banned his Bucky, too,
is because I saw his...
I saw all his...
All he's been practicing was Bucky the last two days.
Hmm.
Can he aim good?
That's what he...
That's what Connor said.
I didn't say it.
He said it.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, plant the seed.
Plant the wall.
Uh-huh.
Oh.
Squid POV.
Nice.
Marvel Rivals.
That's unfortunately that they got domination as their map
too.
Domination is such a hard, like, it's a very refreshing game
mode in the tournament.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Because you got to adjust so fast.
Do you know how fast the game is there?
Looks like Duby's team is winning.
I like that.
I've never seen this Namor skin.
What is this?
That's the newest one, right?
It's the Dave the Dead.
Oh, Dave the Dead.
Oh, okay.
What the hell are you aiming at, man?
He's so blue.
Lazu's head.
Yeah, it's so blue.
It's so blue.
He's a smurf.
The friend is cool, though.
I really like the front too.
I don't doubt it.
I'm just saying he's blue as hell.
That's true.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
Take it back.
Blur my back.
See, he's smurfing.
He got him.
Nice.
That's insane.
Bar.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
Yeah, that is so insane.
Guys, maybe he is nasty.
What did I say?
I mean, we did ban, we did the hell of ban, right, on this
team.
See, that's why we got, yeah, that's why we got rid of the
team up for them.
So they can't, yeah.
That's why, that's why we did that.
So they won't have the team up.
Oh, oh, oh, he's, oh, no, he ran her over.
Oh, do they have a support off?
They did, they have a Luna.
I'll be right back.
I gotta use the bathroom.
They have a rocket right after.
amplifier oh oh my god oh my god this is nasty oh my god oh
my god
that's so crazy that was good that was good alt management
on her team um running out of water uh get water go get some
go get some Soon.
You got 40 seconds.
Oh shit, you're right.
There's matches.
Yeah, go now.
Go now.
Be your back.
Hey, he's dancing.
He's dancing.
He's moving.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey.
Is this allowed?
Um, um.
What do you mean?
Oh, nothing.
Okay.
Oh!
Did you hear me?
that what did he say he kind of goes i think blur is just
such an annoying person on team dubie
yeah that more hella combo like the team up is so strong
that's crazy
oh oh oh oh he's going band for band up there damn oh oh oh
oh well oh oh oh they got him that was insane oh my all
right he's he's been playing in their faces a little bit too
much she got his ass it's the cockiness i
really don't like this map is really hard for me i don't
like this set of maps i feel like i lose a lot I mean, at
least it's played, so I don't think there's like a good
chance of it being played against.
I think it's just random maps each time, so I don't think it
has any bearing.
Oh.
Ooh.
I'm like paranoid my stuff is going to turn off because
ESA's stuff turned off.
I'm sorry.
No, no.
That's like a chronic problem that I've been having.
It's just me, and it's just once, and then it stops.
It's, I don't know what's wrong.
It might be my GPU, but I just got a new one, so it should
be okay.
oh you've planted the seeds of doubt okay sorry my back i'm
back i'm back welcome back you know it'd be hella evil as if
my power went out it's gone out four times in the past two
weeks oh don't say that don't say that i feel like you get a
pause for that right yeah we do my power grid explodes you
get a pause we yeah maybe we can grab an emergency sub i'll
go to my friend's house and use her yeah move i gotta use
your stop oh jesus
that's crazy i can't believe he lives
well they got it we're about to go to our next match we're
going against sk it's yeah okay okay yeah they're gonna win
i mean yeah they're gonna win this uh we're up against dubie
after yeah right up against almost no no no after I thought
I only was out.
No, but we still had to play everyone.
We had to play everyone once.
We still had to play magic against them.
I see.
Yeah.
Okay.
But like in the finals, we play against Stubby's team if
they win this.
Hmm.
I like how excited Connor is.
It's really fun.
He's a very competitive person, isn't he?
I know he used to play Apex too, a lot.
Oh yeah, I forgot about that.
He had like an Apex.
He had like an Apex arc, a League arc.
Yeah.
He's just a very competitive person too.
Mm-hmm.
oh earlier he was like i'm really glad we're doing
competitive games yeah they got the emma alt in time oh my
god oh i'm surprised he didn't portal the emma alt of doom
and despair yeah i'm surprised in emma oh they didn't portal
it that was a good game yeah that was hard yeah god
dang all right we just gotta wait for our lobby.
Okay.
Exciting.
Losing the stream.
Getting ready.
Cracking knuckles.
Opening my game.
Hoping it doesn't crash again.
Locking in.
Oh.
Whoa.
Alright, someone invite me.
I think I have too many things open.
Okay, close that oh
yeah okay oh shit is the time how do i see the themes uh the
button near the word team see uh join in the top or top
right i get an invite please
yeah yay we're on the wrong side guys it's the right side oh
oh so i was like how you all you all followed me like i
thought for myself yes they were like yeah i didn't know
there were actual i didn't know there were actual names like
written on the team i thought it was just i also didn't know
yeah so are we going back to back after this oh i know we i
think we'll get a short break okay okay okay we have to we
there's bat we have to do the bat i'm going to be doing
because look at the map okay okay got it oh yeah
oh oh never
mind back to random okay wouldn't be funny if it goes back
they see so that's the map
All right.
Here we go, y'all.
Woohoo!
There we go.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot to say R.
Is R stand for ready?
Yeah.
Oh, they're in restroom.
I'm R, though.
I didn't ask you guys if you're ready, but I know I'm ready.
You're ready?
Nah.
You're ready.
We're ready, ladies.
Yes, captain.
Glory to the Doki Empire.
Man, shiny.
Let's go.
Choo-choo.
What do we get if we win?
Money.
Oh, shit.
Did you not know?
Did you not look?
did not know we get money since
he didn't know i'll take his money yeah me too good choice
yeah let's all split heavenly's money yeah yeah he's just
playing a play yeah he's playing for fun let's split his
pool yeah yeah we're not we're here for the money right guy
what's fun i don't know what that means getting money is fun
boop boop boop boop boop
Marbell or Rye Bells
Bum bum Bum bum You're also tired of this stupid AI baby
What what?
What the fuck are you talking about?
I'm actually gonna put this in the damn team chat Oh, match
is starting Never mind, okay You're safe this time.
I don't even see what map we're getting.
Barren Dachala.
Dachala.
Again?
Wait, it's domination.
Okay, it's domination.
Okay.
All right, then.
All right.
No, I know what to man.
We're not gotching.
This is the map that they played earlier.
Shift time.
No, this domination is different.
Oh.
My favorite.
I'm swimming.
I'm under the water.
Yeah, we banish Ilock.
all right no more gotcha time because this map is strong
we're against i wonder who they're gonna target man they too
you think they're gonna leave a gambit i don't have we seen
oh we played a gambit we played one gambit one without yeah
oh mr fantastic that's for you you gotta bear you gotta bear
sidelog now yeah take the fun away That's my main.
Don't say that.
What the fuck?
I'm sorry.
That's not my main.
That's not his main, guys.
He's lying.
That's actually not his main.
For those who are wondering, we're not actually lying.
My main is, Jeff.
Oh, and that's for you.
Really?
Man.
Pick your hero.
Poor villain.
I'm not judging.
All right.
Okay, here we go.
show uh what do we do here it's the same it's just it's the
same
my group wasn't even doing nothing no you had crazy ults
though bro yeah you always were crazy yeah and i like uh
anti it just it was so there was so much damage yeah each
and every time it's so good i have to get a little
Oh, it's this one.
Yeah, I'm not playing penny on this.
Fuck that.
Oh, yeah.
Be careful of that.
You know how to deal with Hella, right?
Hella, on this map, I don't.
No, no, for our iron fist.
You know how to deal with Hella, right?
As long as you don't get stunned, you should be fine.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, they're not coming out.
Oh, they're trying.
They don't want to show their comp.
They don't.
guys guys guys seven seven second seven seconds okay okay
okay okay all you need to do is capture the missionary oh
they're running but are we gonna keep going left oh they're
yeah they're running bucks now right or straight on we're
gonna have to swap off loki here again yeah yeah i got Going
right slowly You guys can go for me tanks can come through
from yeah, we're going man.
We're going man Yeah, we can get point we can get point
point come come to him.
Don't worry.
We can help you here.
You're fine Relax SK.
You don't got to pull me like that I'm already a fan.
We don't have I got I got I got I got dumped I got dumped.
I got dumped.
Yeah
There's so much focus on Ah Oh no, it's nice It's okay.
We might have to give we're down too.
Yeah, it's fine, but we can get we can just stay here for as
long as we can We're getting we're getting yeah, we're
getting power in charge.
Yeah, yeah, it's fine.
We're just getting all charged here See what they wasted
that to get that point just don't use any we don't have
anything.
Oh, oh Okay, just back out a word.
It's time to go swap off.
Oh wait, never mind It's fine.
You're fine for now We might We might have to swap off our
into this because uh no worries do you want to go tank all
good dps yep yeah okay just back up back up heavenly back up
back up okay what do we want for dps um and the more is fine
okay what's the word all right here you go let's go up i
will here you guys ready we're going to engage with that
yeah all right three two one go
Anti?
They use double support out.
They double support all of this.
Go for the cloak.
Oh, they broke it.
Oh.
Can you copy me?
Copy me.
When you ulti?
Okay.
I'm ulti.
Oh, damn.
Oh, I don't know.
I couldn't.
Come on, Bucky.
I don't have cleanse.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Poke's on Bucky.
Nice.
I got him.
Binana though.
I gave her a mean right click.
Oh, my God.
That's her in her face.
I'm going to check her out.
Yeah, that was good.
Good swap.
Thank you.
I feel like I wasn't doing it.
You got to get on Loki now.
They got the moon night.
Yeah, they want you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You guys, okay.
We'll use Invis all here so we can get that swap in.
Okay.
Well, you try and, okay, use it defensively still.
We'll still use it defensively.
But you sit like in a way where it's gonna be your judgment.
We get strange, we get strange.
Yeah, he's out of position.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Run them down.
All ID, all ID.
Just run them down.
Hit them as hard as you can.
Back up, back up, back up, back up, back up.
I got you.
They have Moon Knight all here.
Okay.
I have ulty, I have ulty, yeah.
We have Pornling, we're planning on Pornling.
And I have a- I'm gonna ult them, I can ult them.
Yeah, yeah when they portal.
Yeah, and I'll ult first and then you ult them.
But they're not?
Oh, he didn't decide portal, I guess.
They're gonna use it for last leg.
I'm ulting this, ready?
Don't I don't, don't I bolt, don't I bolt.
Kite that.
Nice, nice, nice.
Kite that are getting the invisible.
Yeah, yeah.
Got him.
Nice, nice.
I'm stunned, I'm stunned.
I got you, I got you.
Wait, Amma?
Hey, backline, care backline, care backline.
It's fine, do you.
Oh, it's not fine.
It's fine, it's fine.
Oh, I'm dead, I'm dead.
We still have a fight, we still have a fight.
Okay, swap.
These ultis.
Do you want our portal?
No, no, no, don't portal.
We're gonna portal last fight.
We still have a fight here.
We still can't have a coffee, too.
Alright, come here.
Come here.
Come with me.
We're waiting on.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Come on.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
We wait.
It's fine.
All right, we got to go.
We go.
Go up.
Go up here.
We take his high ground.
We take his high ground away.
Here.
I'm dropping.
SK's out of the fight right now.
Nice.
I got a whale.
SK altered herself?
Okay.
Got it.
Got her, guys.
Nice.
The whale.
Get the cloak, get the cloak.
Nice, they have the portal.
They have, I'm gonna go up.
I'm gonna go up.
Got her.
Nice.
You can't portal.
Oh my god.
So why did she alter herself?
She was alting all three supports.
All of us were up there.
in bone for that yeah i anti-i trade in time they they're
playing uh penny now they're playing penny i don't know if
that was like an excessive no more old but it was really
funny um do you want me to play wolf or i can go strange as
well actually i can i think it's fine fine for now i can i
can go tank if you want to go back to dps uh are they still
on bucky or no but uh if they're not Okay, I don't know.
Let's just play it.
Keep right now and then if it doesn't work, we swap back to
our original comp.
Can do.
If your Discord crashes, tell us in game chat so we can
pause for you.
I didn't say we see, but...
I don't know if you heard me.
No.
Oh, now I can hear you.
Okay.
Now we can hear you.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm just gonna play strange here.
Okay.
I'm totally fine with that we were on the right side.
I went to the right entrance instead I was like, we're
right.
Where's the door?
Where is everyone?
No, I was like, where's my door?
Wait, where's their penny?
They're putting SK on a tank now
Oh, I missed my anti.
Oh, let him know I have ults in I've ults here so stabilize
we can don't get picked Get here.
Ready?
Free?
Yeah.
Okay, wait, actually.
Three, two, one.
They are down.
They're down, go, go, go, go, go.
Let's keep going.
Let's keep going, get me, get me, get me, get me.
Got him!
Nice, nice, nice.
Meg is alone.
Meg is alone, stagger him.
No, we have to kill.
Kill him out.
Max can do a lot of damage.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
You never stagger at that.
We're good.
Good job, good job.
You just stagger swishes.
Yes.
Get back here!
Yes!
This team is just so fucking free!
I'm playing a game with both of my feet!
Oh, I've never heard that remix before.
That's new to me.
I have ulti.
That's good.
Okay, try and like hide for it.
Hide for it.
And then fly up and I'll...
I'm going above.
I'm going... Actually, no.
I can play aggro.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
If you can't look for a stranger.
Portal broke.
Oh, no.
We're down one, we're down one.
We have ulted.
They ulted.
Gambit ulted.
Gambit, ulted.
Punisher ulted.
Back up.
Oh, wait.
It's a server?
Oh, there's a huge flag right now.
Yeah, there's a flag.
He's captured more than half of the mission area.
I'm never knowing.
We're down to healer.
It's fine, fine.
Fight.
Die on point.
Just die on point.
bullshit hey 60 61 i got that server lag too yeah i i had a
little i still have ulti i was saving i couldn't i couldn't
do anything uh copy me and then yeah and then we go with the
stranger wait for me wait for me yeah back back wait wait
don't don't push up why does it feel right Let's go.
I'm gonna let you heal more.
I'm gonna let you hear.
Okay, we're ready?
You're gonna copy me.
My fucking mind.
I got it too too.
Look for the ult.
Wait for that.
Wait for the ult.
Look for the ult.
Yo, multiple ults.
Multiple ults.
I got shielded.
They got shielded.
It got shielded.
It's fine.
All thing does?
Go, go, go.
Oh, okay.
They're all doing it.
Yeah, yeah, they all did.
Cloak here.
It's fine.
You gotta do it fast.
Yeah, yeah.
I tried to get a bad spot.
Nice block.
All right, I'm stepping on point.
Invis.
Invis one.
They're down to healer.
Down to healer.
I got him!
Got him!
I'm gonna go for help!
Cat point!
He's alone!
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Got her.
Nice kill, nice kill, nice kill.
We don't have any...
Okay, don't heal.
Don't heal too much.
Let our Sue heal.
Come on back.
Come back.
Yeah, go on Heavenly.
Come back to like the Sue heal.
We can heal the Mag.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We need to build this up.
So let the Sue heal.
They're just walking up.
I'm going to use the portal as the last fight.
So I'm going to go to my, I'm going to look to our left.
There are left.
They're on the left, too.
Careful.
There's two on the left.
Oh, fuck it.
They're going hard left.
They're really deep in their left.
It's fine.
Okay, one healer is dead left.
Ah, uh, what's his name?
He's not, it's down.
It's fine.
They ulted.
Gimpe ulted.
Use the, you'll, use.
Oh, no, I got you.
You have my name?
Get off of my support!
I got a I got a I got fun.
Nice to see that in you night.
Let's go!
I crashed my car into my brain!
Yes!
Yeah, I saw that.
That was insane.
SK, what like these?
What are you talking about?
Oh my god.
I don't care.
I love it.
I don't care though.
Dude, three time MVP.
Crazy.
yeah let's go do we go straight to the finals like we played
i feel like they give us a break or yeah i want a little
break here yeah just a tiny little break as a treat yeah i
think we are
like maybe like a dinner break three and oh guys oh my god a
dinner break yeah that's yeah that's how yeah we can we come
back in 30 minutes like we're gonna order food let's make
this a two-day venture could come back another day man i'm
tired yeah day two day two yeah yeah for sure i don't think
i'm gonna be cracked out like this tomorrow i think this is
i have to play our creators tomorrow right now i've got our
creators tomorrow they nerf the editor i don't know what any
of that means i haven't played it yet what do you mean
that's okay is our creators worth getting into i keep
hearing i mean right now yes yeah it's fun yeah it's just a
fun time i didn't have too much uh interest when i tried it
out it was okay i really like the finals which was the game
that the same team made oh the finals made that game yeah i
didn't know that i love the finals if you so the way that uh
arc raiders goes is that solos and duos people are like
pretty chill once you enter trios it's like a bloodbath it's
just apex people want to kill you and rip your head off oh
so they don't want to don't shoot there's no don't shoot
sometimes but it's the most don't shoot people are Oh, wait.
Oh, I'm just, we made it to the finals.
Woohoo!
I'm proud of y'all.
I'm, whatever happens, we did it.
We got in the finals.
I'm such a fucking genius.
So my ads are running, but that doesn't mean people have to
watch.
Go to the other channel.
You're having your like foreshadowing beach right now.
Oh, my God.
I'm just glad that we made it.
a break or what i think it's just like five like it was like
a five minutes or something
okay i'm shaking i'm so scared can i have can i get my water
yeah i think so they're still interviewing they're
interviewing right now go get your water i'm gonna
disassociate for a bit too
guys i'm gonna i'm looking at i need to calm down what do i
get for dinner thoughts i'm getting pizza pizza oh pizza
yeah pizza really good
oh my god um i'm really proud of my team we didn't practice
we strategized a lot i i used my time because like all of
our schedules put mine up um we're just gonna keep we're
gonna keep doing our best and and working together and and
swapping when when it used to and it'll be okay like
heavenly only played with us for two hours for today like
yesterday he couldn't like that was the first time we were
able to play together as a team like two hours before the
stream uh before the tournament because like uh because he
couldn't make it to yesterday's scrim so so i'm really proud
of us we're able to like do that this well we're not having
that much practice together as a team It's like your push
cookie says.
Oh, I'm so happy.
Tomorrow you will become Chinese.
I was so stressed out.
God, I fucking wish.
I was really stressed out.
Come on, so listen to creativity of others.
I thought I muted the soundboard.
How is it still coming through?
That's insane.
Oh my, is it like, did you just do it on a go XLR?
It's a, yeah, it's like, it's a ported through one.
Yeah, I was like, I fucking mute it.
all your sound words on this screen i was not having it i
was not having the soundboard shit that is so funny oh my
god yeah um but oh my gosh i'm just at a really chinese
point in our life um oh she don't want to talk to us no more
oh sorry i was just associating us you're good you're good
you're good i'm so i'm just you know whatever happened just
that we made it to the they said we're getting it they said
we're getting a quick break thank oh oh how quick is that
okay i would say five go get water go use the bathroom order
food yeah it's a five it is five okay okay i'm yeah i know
that my teammates need to be on my screen to get i know that
um the thing is like my supports aren't even going to go
straight in anyway the reason why i don't do that for my
supports is that like i i'm more i'm trying to make sure
because i have to make the reaction quick so like i can't
just like run back and then all I'm focusing on the fact
that my DPS and tanks are in front of me and they are the
most important people to get the ult.
So, like, if I have to make a snap decision, I'm not going
to have to...
I'm not going to look back and then make sure everyone's in
my view and then I'll...
I have to make a snap decision in my ult and be like, these
are the people that I need to do damage, that can do damage.
Who...
Are we going up against Duby?
yeah our next match is with yeah yeah okay best of three
best of three technically we never went to losers so i don't
think there's losers in this one no there's no i wanted my
extra free one point so it's best two out of our best so we
have to play two times instead of three times or one time
each match they ban they do bans again it's the rank bands
it's the same i think they might just do it they either do
the same bands or they target new bands to make it work okay
so the thing is um we we have to win two games basically
instead of one oh wait what the okay i'm trying to remember
what were the bands that we did i mean dubie's team is very
strong Like, it's just...
Blur.
Blur is just a very strong player.
I forget who we back against them.
You know what they...
Do you know what they banned out?
Oh, yeah.
I'm gonna look at my history and see what they banned out.
Blah.
What is this?
They banned out Magic.
get an invis i think they did the invis just so they can run
wolf no my friend once was like can i watch the replay of
your game against bro i don't know i'll give you my replay
did it copy did i do it i think you can oh is it that oh it
is okay i got the replay code yeah my friend is like guys oh
just watching the countdown it's very slowly yeah i'm gonna
restart my game real quick all right okay okay just because
i've been lagging oh no that's not good
i gotta play gambit let's go that's all yeah this is the
games have all been very fun yeah well it's because well to
be fair it's because we're winning so We have to be a bummer
because we're winning.
Does that diminish the fun that I'm having?
No.
But we got to give context as to why we're having fun.
We had close games, though.
Yeah, there are some very tight games.
I mean, Dewey's team is very strong, so the games have been
very, very tight.
You know, that was fun.
That was fun.
All right.
To my sound guy, brought up the people that you told me to
bring up.
in this grade oh
okay 30 30 seconds 30 seconds no 30 seconds no give us five
more minutes five more minutes please please
boom boom boom boom
like how i looked at my i looked at what we banned and i
already forgot he's back why did i ban yay
i banned okay bucky hello okay
cammon okay may i get an invite yeah i'm going i'm joining
the uh the thing right now oh wait it's a new one
yeah they started a new lobby nice i'm waiting for my
english oh nice thank you yay tank tank we're in the we're
in the don't worry guys we're on the right side this time
you mean the left side yeah the left side
there we go before y'all jump my ass No, I saw that.
First round map.
No.
Oh, random domination map and then lose.
Wait, are we doing this?
I don't know.
They're actually doing this type loser picks.
Oh, loser picks?
No, no, random domination map.
Then second map, the loser picks.
Wow.
Never done that before.
That's just like, like actually competitive is like that.
Oh, that's good.
Okay, the pizza places near me were closed.
I got Thai food.
Oh, no.
Pizza being closed?
Usually pizza is like the one that's 24-7.
No, there's one place near me that does it so good and they
close it.
Seven.
Somebody has like, do I keep rolling and plating and silver?
The ranks just reset, guys.
Everyone's ranks just reset.
They're not actually plating silver.
Okay.
This is so good.
This is the only time where I tried ranked and I won all 10
placements.
Good for you.
My placements were ass.
Same.
Yeah, it was like 50, 50.
I was like...
Apparently everyone starts at bronze three.
So I just ended, I started bronze three and then I ended in
gold two.
Oh.
Yeah.
That's weird.
That's crazy.
clan i had elo terror risers in my games like they were they
were like not real i don't even know what was going on there
the guy with this the 600 damage and the one kill that was
in one of my placements and he was screaming at me i didn't
heal him enough my bad elo terrorists oh they're everywhere
i
simply told myself i will only open voice comms when i get
to higher elo it's there's low-key sometimes people are just
as mean like yeah yeah yeah i think rival's has is like
almost as toxic as valorant now oh yeah oh yeah the amount
of times where it's like you open calm and you just like
give a give like a call out and then they just like they're
like oh woman sorry woman on our team we're gonna lose i
don't talk i'm not gonna talk to you anymore so i never use
voice comes all i do is ping
Oh, they're doing an interview right now with Duby's team,
so we're just waiting.
Are they going to interview you next?
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
We'll see.
Hey, Doki.
Hello.
Oh.
Would you like to come up and do one more interview?
Oh, yeah, she.
Okay, I guess I am doing an interview.
Oh, which channel?
I am the predictor.
Which one?
Do I just go to the main channels?
us uh mouse and monkey oh okay so i can just go right now
yeah okay cool oh gotta pull up this all right see you guys
there hello hey guys undefeated so far don't don't don't
don't don't jinx this man don't you couldn't possibly lose
you said you're over defeat don't jinx this man guys You're
gonna do great.
I'm proud of you.
You're amazing.
And you're a great gambit player.
Oh, thank you.
And then you're gonna ban my gambit now?
No!
Oh, no!
I hope they don't ban your gambit.
I've been loving that Jeffstrat you guys have been doing.
Oh, wait, the Jeffstrat?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, they don't know what we're...
Oh, are you, Jeff?
Yeah, yeah.
We're preventing the stream snipers.
Ooh.
So, you guys had that game against 2B.
It was very close it was yeah did you expect it to be that
close were you i did because um i know that some of the
players on dubious teams and like what they play i know like
ugly is one them i know blur is a very very good fps player
because he is apex predator um for many seasons so like i
know he's a very he basically his fps skills can transfer to
any game so okay um so like i knew his cps was really strong
um and they're very coordinated too and he's very flexible
so like he could play a lot of characters so like a lot of
things yeah so like we can't really target ban him so um at
best like we try our best to like strategically what can we
survive like at the most makes sense and you know there's
some ults that we can't survive so we have to ban that true
is there any strategy change you're gonna do going into this
or you just play in the same game and how can it goes like
it really depends on what they're trying to ban because we
know our band line um and so it's like what if obviously
they want to try and ban something else on us because their
first band line didn't work out i mean it did but like in a
way where they want to win the next game so obviously
they'll try to do a different ban to see which will actually
have help them win the game so our strategy just depends on
what their band line is because that's how our comps change
instantly interesting you i i've seen your text channel you
guys have got like the Bible of strategies to look at the
little notepad that I used it right there's so many notepads
of like if this happens it's like a flowchart extravaganza
like a little flowchart if they banned this we go to this if
they banned that we go to this like but my team yeah and my
because I'm looking at it right now like whoa okay because
that's what rivals is like usually it's not it's like it's
not really about like for esports it's not about who has the
best individual play like best team players it's also about
like the band line too because it changes everything so it's
like rock paper scissors so if they if someone messes up the
band line if a team messes up the band line it's over
because the other team has a better comp that can rock paper
scissors your comp so it's literally like a mind game all
right i guess we'll we'll see how it goes in this final best
of three good luck and thanks for putting on the show so far
yeah we will appreciate it thank you for having us i did not
see myself in the final so i'm hey yeah we're here good luck
good luck good luck thank you thank you guys bye bye bye bye
bye no oh my god hello i'm back good interview
all right time almost time let's do it so this is the back
to back to back right yeah oh are we ready yeah let me type
r in the game i didn't realize they were typing it in the
lobby r there we We think they didn't even press R.
I readied up.
Realize, breathing.
I know somehow I'm gonna get there and be so wonderful.
It's all for real.
I hear your wild bangers.
I hear them.
Team doobsters?
Are you ready?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
We know who we're banning.
Yeah, I know what we're banning.
I think, give me a sec.
Let me...
I need to pull it up.
Yeah, I know what we're banning.
I almost forgot.
I'm extremely...
Whoa.
Whoa, now it's professional.
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh, this one?
I gotta pull up my...
Wait, so we have three bans?
Yeah, we have three...
Yeah.
Wait, I don't know.
Well...
No, they can put rank.
They can put rank stuff here.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
No, no, no.
This, this is because it's vest of two.
Or vest of three.
Vest of three.
All right.
Vest of two out of three, hunn't it?
Or just fester three?
Hey.
Are you a lord?
Is that a lord?
Wait, that's a good question.
There it is.
Is it first of three or best out of three?
Vest of three.
Best of three.
So if we win two, then...
them all right let's see what they're gonna ban i'm curious
what are you gonna do here what's they banning what's this
is the bat like i'm curious what their new bad line is gonna
be oh okay i knew it i knew it okay i think they're gonna
ban fantastic next is this the name room oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah those are good bands we did last time if it doesn't
work we can i like when we ban hella because like i like
when we ban hella because i can still play no more yeah more
all right let's see okay oh my god all my damn support all
right i'm not judging
oh this is domination okay all right so if they run they
might run wolf here okay so that's why that's why they take
the push they take the seal away so they could have a chance
to run well if they pick wolf should i go back to group
because i can just not get picked up no you don't go grew
when you're when you're against all right do you feel
confident do you feel confident going against wolf yeah yeah
because with the new change to his e i can't get grabbed
anymore so if he can't and i'm on i'm a mantis i'm a mantis
yeah yeah do it i'm a I think it would be okay.
If it doesn't work, just watch the map.
Yeah, no.
If I immediately...
If we need a...
Yeah, yeah.
If we need a shield tank, I can go.
Strange.
Oh, they might need to pause.
They might need a pause.
Yeah.
Pause.
Please.
Okay, we'll just...
I'll do an ad.
Oh, wait.
Well, we have to run up.
We'll run up until they pause.
There you go.
they got it okay because we don't know if they're running as
well that's the thing like at this point they should just
reset the lobby and just keep the same end yeah oh they're
not running okay i wasn't i wasn't sure if they were running
or not i just opened mouse and stream and they were they
were in fact we're closer than they oh oops all right now
don't reset the lobby hold on
the hero selection area so oh nice nice i just jumped oh i
lost my phone where's my phone oh no jack can you call my
phone so i can find it that'd be terrifying if it actually
rings hello hello what's up
i think she had the same problem as us where she has to
reset the we just restart this grade yeah oh i think i'm
gonna stay in my kitchen fuck we're gonna have my second
phone here to watch tiktok jesus christ bro second phone oh
my god i just bought an iphone so i've been watching oh my
god you're so ill dude you're actually ill your brain rotted
yeah i am
okay oh they're good they're good okay yeah yeah just are
you all ready are you all ready just all right all right
ready to go out all right let's roll out he's got the he's
got the double phone strat that's how you know he's single
that's dirty and rude that's facts though i've been playing
eight ball in this bro i mean i got damage these women be
cooking my oh they play Hey Groot too, what's up?
Oh shit, I'm low.
That's fine.
His wall's broken.
Oh, my wall broke a little.
Okay, careful, careful.
Help our Groot, help our Groot.
I'm good.
Not good anymore.
Okay, she's boxed.
She's boxed.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
Okay, bye.
Blur, I'll stab you in the chest, bro.
I think that's gotta go against code of conduct or
something, dude.
You can't be saying that.
I mean, in game, low key in game.
Quick!
We got grip!
All the healers are cut off!
Nice, nice, nice!
Push up!
Push up, push up!
You're down!
They're down too!
Welcome back, come back, come back, come back now.
Come back now!
I'm all here, I have all here.
We'll use my alt first!
And then if...
If the storm alts, you copy me.
So...
He should be close to if not, though.
They're getting...
They got a squirrel girl now.
one go go go go There it is Can I copy do I copy?
Yeah copy me copy me copy me Copy me copy me Oh my god I
can't see you I can't see you That was so many support yeah
It's okay it's okay We have to shoot I'm just gonna die here
I'm gonna die here I'm gonna die here It's fine They're
running shark nato That was so many For shark nato we just
shoot the We just shoot the It's good you didn't copy me
because I didn't realize they have jeff nato That was my bad
Okay We run Mantis, no?
Alright, we run Mantis, uh, Mantis, Iron Fist Alt first.
Okay, ready?
Copy me, copy me, copy me.
Okay, alright, go, go, go, go, go.
Go.
It's fine.
Shoot the squirrels, shoot the squirrels.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, help him, help him.
Help up, push up, push up, push up, help him.
Alright.
They're down, down, down, too, down, too, down, too, down,
too.
Nice, nice, line, push up, help him.
No more, no more, no more, no more, no more, no more.
No more, no more, no more.
Clean, clean, clean, clean.
Too late!
Evan!
I strapped!
Listen, listen, listen!
That looked like a failed alt.
It wasn't.
The second I ulted, I knew he would waste his two.
And he got nothing for it.
That grab was like, that was like so accidental.
Because tanks are literally monkeys, so monkey see, monkey
do.
He's like, oh yeah, I can do that.
Okay, net rocket.
I'll let whenever they do it.
Yo, it's cut off.
He was uncut off.
Ow.
Oh, I'm taking a lot of damage.
Storm, Storm, Storm, Storm, Storm, Storm, Storm, Storm,
Storm, Storm, Storm, Storm, Storm, Storm.
I'm pushing up, pushing up, pushing up, pushing up.
Don't push too.
Oh my god, okay.
We get Emma, we get Emma.
No more else, no more else, no more else, no more else.
Good, good, good, good, good, good, good.
Nice, nice, nice.
For some reason.
All right, all right.
assault is mild they're gonna might use jeff nato if they
use jeff we all disperse if they use jeff nato don't stand
close together okay and we all shoot they're tp they're tp
okay i'm gonna all right here then they oh i'm so high in
the air i'll stand next to you just in case hey i'm gonna
damage boost you okay when he dropped down above above above
oh my god what okay oh i'm gonna put them okay i'm here
we're down we're down we're down go go go go i'm dead Okay.
I have no idea what the hell.
Okay.
Rocket ult.
Rock out next.
Oh, no, never mind!
Don't use anything.
Don't you use anything...
Just die.
Just die, just die.
We use rocket ult.
We have three ulties coming up.
We can farm the Loki, have Loki farm.
Uh, uh, keep don't, don't heal.
Don't heal.
Let our Loki heal.
Okay.
I'm gonna do damage boost.
I have to do that for you, though.
Oh my God.
Okay, perhaps guys, back up, back up.
Back up.
We have Loki all here.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I definitely shouldn't have done that.
I should have done that.
I should have done.
I bet.
Okay, but what if we take this guy?
Hey, strange.
What you doing, man?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I'm here.
We can do it.
We can go.
Oh, no.
It's fine.
I have res.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
We have res.
Oh, no.
It's fine.
I got you.
I'm dead.
Nice, nice, nice.
We're even.
They are penny, they are penny.
I'm switching.
Oh, Elton, Storm.
Storm, oh!
Elton, Elton.
I'm shooting Storm, I'm shooting Storm.
I'm shooting Storm.
I'm going to portal.
Yeah, portal, portal, portal, this, portal this.
I'm going to be, keep me up, keep me up.
Doki Doki.
Okay, you're on the point.
You're on the point.
Touch, touch, touch, touch, touch.
Nice.
I'm coming, but I'm one.
Alt.
All in, all in, all in.
Undefeatable.
It is.
I didn't get any of the healers in the hall, unfortunately.
Jack wants our thing.
Just get the...
Pookie!
Penny dead!
Oh!
Help us!
Protect us!
Protect!
Shoot the Jeff!
He's dead!
He went through his puddle.
He's done one!
Done one!
We can make this work!
Make it work!
Fuck!
Okay, man.
it's okay good try good oh we're still we're still touching
we're still touching ow i'm dead i'm dead okay we have to
swap here we have to swap loki off he's just farming abusing
the he's abusing the moon knight all here okay we save
rocket for jeff nato
like that the the moon knight just abused um the fact that
we have clones We might all wait too many times.
I'm going back to Emma.
We might need mag out for the Jeff ult.
You might have to go mag for that.
You have to save your mag out just for the Jeff E.
Because no one else can kill the Jeff right now.
Or should I go cloak for the Jeff ult?
Do they have a mag?
Were they running mag?
No.
No, okay, it's fine.
If you run through, you go cloak.
And then make sure you cloak us.
Young man wolf still.
They have an Emma and a strange, I think?
No.
uh emma and penny all right you guys still fine with
overring we're fine with i think this will work i'm gonna
this doesn't work i'll switch to mag okay i'm gonna keep
save mantis but if it doesn't work i'm swapping to luna okay
i also don't mind playing tank yeah i can swap with you if
you want to just call you call it i'll move around you dude
okay or i can hawkeye because they're all far back and no
one's really putting a lot of pressure i don't mind playing
mag i can mag they're running penny now i hear it i need
assistance Can we get unks, unks, unks?
I got it, I got it.
I got it.
Oh, shit.
I'll roll myself off for a second.
We can push up a little.
We have, um, fine.
Okay, okay.
No, no more, no more, no more, no more.
I can't really go in.
Yeah, they're, they're getting, oh, they're getting it for
free.
We let them have it for free.
Oh, we just use our cloak up, cloak up, cloak up, cloak up
this cloak.
Damn, why?
You got the shit already?
Yeah, that's why.
All right, look.
We get, we can get, we can get, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, I got her.
I got her.
I'm dead.
Nice.
We have to die for this.
I have to die for it.
Spread out.
I didn't need that, but that's OK.
We didn't need that.
Oh, wait.
We do.
We do, actually.
Never mind.
I missed.
It's fine, it's fine.
It's fine.
I can't get him.
All right, so we're going to use my alt to engage here.
I have ult.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, I have ult also.
But we could probably save them.
Mine.
All right, ready?
Three, two, one.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
They're cutting you.
They're going to try and kite it.
Good one.
Oh, I got it.
Back up.
Cite up.
Cite up, Cite up, Cite up, Cite up.
Back up, back up, back up.
She's alone.
Kill this.
Panny, Panny, Panny, Panny.
I'm alting, I'm alting.
I'm alting.
Look at the gold.
Get out.
Pull them to the wall.
What the hell's going on?
It's just a mass moving.
God damn it.
Man.
We don't have support else here.
We have to...
I'm low.
I guess I got Penny.
I got Penny.
Penny did.
He ate me.
I died.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't kill him.
Yeah.
We're going to need mag.
Swap to mag here.
I saw you.
Believe me.
I'll go go go go.
I'll go.
I got you, I got you.
We need mag up for the Jeff.
For Jeff.
Yep.
And the cloak too.
I have my ult.
We can push with it.
Yeah, nice.
Do they have shields?
No.
They're gonna have Munayel though.
Okay.
We have to shoot it.
We just have to shoot it.
We batted it.
Shoot it.
We had to shoot that.
It's fine.
Bye, bye, bye.
You're down one.
We can keep going.
It's nice, nice, nice.
Keep going.
We're even.
I'm ulting.
She's grabbing me.
Cloak off this.
Actually, yeah, cloak off.
Cloak off.
And then Adam, see alive.
Oh.
You have Riz.
I'm ulting.
Riz is.
Oh, he wants you.
It's fine.
I'm going in.
Are we all here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, my God.
This blur storm is crazy.
But you have to focus on blur.
We can't.
Emma, Emma, Emma, focus Emma.
Focus, Emma.
Right here.
I'm alone on point.
I'm blocking.
I don't see her.
On me.
She's fucking looping me.
There you go.
So you're going to have storm we don't have support alt for
this so we all have to shoot the storm if anything yeah they
switch they switch the they switch their tp they're gonna
have storm alt we have no support alt we have to shoot it
they're nowhere near the tp because they're trying to fight
me so bad we are gonna have to if they run this again we
have to run luna instead of cloak i don't think cloak is
working okay i'll switch to luna if i die okay they're gonna
have luna oh here they're gonna have about Moon Knight, so
careful.
Jeffy, Meg, remember to give it, give it.
Here, here.
Oh, what?
He did, he's dead, he's dead, he's dead.
Oh, blur you bitch.
He's fucking ultimate on top of me.
I'm getting fucking juggled.
Oh, I'm gonna swap.
Someone has to swap to Strange.
Okay, okay.
Actually, I got it, I got it, I got it.
I got it, I got it.
Someone guard me?
What?
Oh my God, what?
It's not working.
Oh my God, I'm sorry.
My thing bugged.
Oh no.
I'm lucky.
It's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
forgot two more my thing bugged out i was trying to i was
trying to portal and then my keys bugged out there
do you want to still keep me on dps then i feel like we were
able to i need something to contest moon night moon night's
just getting fucking hell of free damage i'm able to i think
i think jeff is way too disruptive right now okay all right
don't we ban him next time it's just this This map is a Jeff
map.
This is a Jeff map.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We still got two more.
We've done worse.
The thing is, we- we have to swap Loki off.
We have to focus on- Okay, let me figure out this bad line.
because we don't want to give them bucky no so we keep that
dead we have to keep the bucky ben and the thing is we have
to shoot on the map we have to shoot the storm that's like
we pick we pick the map oh we picked on this one oh um how
much time do we have 27 seconds 30 seconds oh fuck i didn't
know we were gonna pick the map are we doing convergence of
convoy if we do convoy we do convoy we should do convoy
which one let's do Tokyo actually no they have a storm
player um I'm thinking his guard both suck so I mean all
three suck a storm so you might as well pick Tokyo or his
guard all right oh wait I'm trying to pick it oh did it pick
it for us oh hello are we nope it picks random what I picked
it what this wasn't even on the this wasn't even on we're in
china i cannot be late all right this works it didn't let me
pick uh it didn't let me pick well good news this is not a
jeff map so we don't have to worry about banning jeff okay
okay we do bucky still yep uh believe let's just pause yeah
we'll do pause soon okay If they first ban Gambit, we ban
Storm.
Okay.
Hello?
Hey.
Okay, we ban Storm.
All right.
Is this not a name right, Matt?
This is?
Yeah, this is.
Oh, wait.
This is a hell map.
Ben, hell, a banana, a banana, a banana, a banana.
All four of you.
Ben, hell, a, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no.
gotcha messed up.
We actually wanted to ban... Oh no.
We can make it work.
We can just play home.
Hell, like, can you... Can we honor that?
We had a joke.
Yeah.
Majority of us pick.
Fuck no.
They're gonna say no.
We're gonna need to restart this if we want to do that.
Yeah.
I didn't really realize...
hella if they don't hella instead of storm is our bad line
but they can't get storm we have to we have to restart oh we
don't yeah can we start lobby and restart and you'll honor
honor the map
30 seconds before you attack get ready i'll do it yeah we'll
honor same bands the same bands and same maps except for
hella over storm.
Yeah, there you go.
That was unfortunate.
For sure, for sure.
I forgot that we were on that map.
It's okay.
They want to know if you're ready.
Yeah.
Alright.
We have to down hard because that was a whole map too.
It fucking sucks.
My thing lagged.
I couldn't like pick it.
It wasn't only me.
Was I the only one allowed to pick the map?
Yeah.
Oh, they're...
Okay.
We're in China.
Oh, my poor Biao, baby.
Oh, she is.
Oh, man.
Oh, jean.
Oh, fucking.
Wow, you're more Chinese than I am.
You've caught me in a very Chinese part of my life.
I am banished in this match.
I went to pick Jeff.
What are we doing?
It doesn't matter.
It's okay.
So, Ben.
Ben, Bucky, Hella.
We just got to honor that.
Who did they ban again?
What support did you want me on?
If they run, we run Loki first.
If they run Moon Knight, you swap off.
a low key instantly okay for res you have um you have to
wait until two people die and don't res in the middle of the
point that's really it um but like the most ideal playing a
storm we have to play luna that's the most ideal but with
that your hero pool is so limited because if we play luna
you have to play either we could try and make adam work but
i also have to swap to something because we need to play
Luna against like Storm okay I can't we can go fuck okay we
can try and go Rocket, Luna, Loki for now Rocket, Luna, Loki
yeah
I like this I like this alright, we got this so Luna will
focus on the we'll focus on alting for storm and we have to
I think if they have a storm we need a hit scan we need a
hit scan you need you know I played Punisher heavenly yeah
okay we might have to run Emma I'm playing back Emma
Punisher I'm a Punisher all right yes sir I need you to be
on Punisher they're on storm
Or do you know how to play Phoenix?
Phoenix is the best character against Storm.
I have it later yet.
It's fine.
We can try and make this.
Yeah, yeah.
All you need to do is capture the mission.
Kind of unfortunate because...
Don't go too far.
Swap up Loki.
I just wanted to.
I just need the vision.
Yeah.
There's no reason to play it.
I'm going to use this to replace.
Yeah.
Up top, up top, up top.
I was fine.
We're not up top.
We need someone to...
Oh, the server's lagging.
Okay, that's fine.
It keeps lagging on this map specifically, I noticed.
Too much fog.
They have a storm.
They have a storm, but our Punisher is going to be dealing
with that.
That fucked up so bad.
My hook did not.
Hopefully it was a hook.
Okay, okay, okay.
We have Res.
Res here.
Yeah, we have.
Can we get Moon Knight up there still?
I can't get him.
Yeah, yeah.
They both focused me at the same time.
Oh, behind, behind.
Yep.
Storm's up close.
Yeah.
I might be able to kill her.
No, I can't get her.
Oh, nice.
She's dead.
Keep going.
I'm okay.
I'm all here.
Keep going.
Jeff down.
They're down two.
Down two.
Good.
Nice.
Okay, when use the, if they storm out, use the, use the bind
for Adam, like the soul link.
Use the soul link for them.
Yeah, the moment, but don't, don't soap on when you hear the
ult.
Soap on when you, when you see the ult comes out and soap
on.
Not when she, not when she starts it, when she puts it down.
Yeah.
Got it.
Almost have res.
We soap on and if our, if it looks like we're still dying,
Lunol.
Oh, it's fine, it's fine.
That's fine, mate.
Are you stronger on that guy?
He switched the Hawkeye.
Okay, okay.
Nice.
Okay.
Here, Moon Knight ult you, by the way.
Yeah, yeah, they'll have Moon Knight all here.
I can ult this.
I kind of want to ult this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, do it, do it.
Don't hesitate, don't hesitate.
I got Moon Knight.
Nice, nice, nice.
Don't hesitate.
Yo, Spini's on the side.
I need help.
They did not let me capitalize on that.
Here, I got you.
I got you.
Pini's shit's on the side.
Lurr don't make me do this!
Do it.
You have to.
You have to kill him.
You have to kill him!
You want the money so bad!
You gotta kill him!
Okay.
We have...
Yeah.
So find us if you can?
Oh, that's fine.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine.
I can't, I can't ulti.
I couldn't, I couldn't.
It's fine, it's fine.
Just die, just die.
They used two healths.
Just never used nothing.
Use nothing.
Okay, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Don't use anything.
Don't, die if you can.
Die if you can.
Or, uh, yeah, yeah.
Use you.
Don't don't don't rest don't rest.
Don't rest.
Yeah, don't rest.
We got a regroup.
We got a regroup Oh, no.
Oh, no heavenly heavenly.
No, I was already way too far out.
Okay.
It's fine.
We'll use my ult to engage
All right.
You guys ready?
Yeah Okay, I need heals here.
All right Here you What is happening That's fine One's low
one's low.
I got i got i got emma i got emma push up push up push up
push up pushing pushing pushing don't get hit by the knees
don't get hit by the knees don't get hit by oh that was my
bad i should have been like careful shoot the what i'm
lagging i was trying to shoot the thing i would i'm lagging
i can you can rest this rest this rest this oh it is lagging
this is yeah this is laggy this is laggy we're we have
numbers we have numbers now nice nice nice keep going keep
going behind me behind me uh penny penny focus on penny's
one penny is one penny is one got her got her got her there
is someone up here you'll be getting away Get the cloak.
Let the cloak.
Focus on cloak.
I got her.
Yeah, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's used it for defensive.
Just don't.
Somebody's coming around underneath.
It's fine.
I'll look.
I have ulti?
I have ulti for it.
Lagging.
Yeah, I'm lagging too.
Nice.
Use this.
You have to use this.
so you don't get eaten.
Hit me here.
I'm here.
Oh, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I have, I'm, it's fine.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, good play, good play.
Oh.
They're using Cloak all?
Fuck.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
No, it's not that I could have one-shot Cloak, but she
webbed me and I missed it.
No, no, you had to choose between Cloak or Jeff.
What the fuck?
Fuck.
Oh, I'm trying to heal.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, Oh, wait, you already had, oh, I thought you
used it already.
I didn't know.
I think we're good.
We're still good.
We're still good, we're still good.
I can't even show it.
Nice, nice.
We're back.
Oh, Thylon.
Thylon?
Oh, Thylon, somebody has au.
Behind you guys.
Binding you guys.
I'm on Moonstice.
Moonnight.
I got him.
Sorry, Blur.
Can we get him.
I got her.
I got Amy, Penny.
Nice.
Good shot.
How far up do we want to push?
One person on cart.
The rest of us be here.
We gotta push it.
We should go QQ.
Yeah, you should build your alt.
Build your alt.
Your alt is one point.
I heard Phoenix.
Scylux coming around here.
It's fine.
That was fine.
Well, thank you.
There you are.
Yeah, you destroyed our res.
So we don't have res.
We don't have res.
I have my own.
Sobond, sobond us, sobond us, sobond us.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
You're sobond, go sobond.
Nice.
Blurred, get blurred, get blurred, nice.
Got him, got him, got him, got him, got him, got him.
Nice, nice, nice.
Push up if you can, push up if you can.
Cloak, Cloak, please, Cloak is one.
Cloak is one.
Mac one, Mac one, Mac one, two, Mac one.
Emma one, Emma one, Emma one, Emma one.
Focus on Emma one, Emma one.
Any heals?
Thank you.
Fucking drop dead.
Emma dead.
Thank you.
I'm pushing, pushing, pushing.
This lag will be the death of you.
Yeah, it's bad.
It's really bad.
No, I agree.
That's bad.
I have bubble for you.
Phoenix on the left side.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
We're dead.
Push, push, push, push.
Kill these guys.
You killed this?
Nice.
They'll pop too.
Use it.
Hide.
Don't fight this.
Uh, Emma's on me.
It's fine.
I'm with you.
No, she was lying.
Mack.
Mac, Mac, Mack, Mac, Mac, Focus on Mac.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Moon night, please, moon night, please.
Nice.
Clean, clean, clean, clean, clean.
Oh, my God.
Oh, this is a very fair match.
I feel like they whipped our asses the first time and like.
Yeah, I love you still feel like I'm getting my ass We run
Pen here.
Yeah.
Are you able to stay on high ground?
I can stay in high ground with you.
You want me to go on high ground?
No, no, Hawkeye.
Okay.
Yeah, because he has to make sure high ground is contested.
Okay, okay.
Heavenly.
What's up?
Did you hear that?
You have to go high ground.
You have to stay on top of that thing on the first point.
Sure thing, boss.
You want me on Mag still?
Yeah, Mag.
Mag is always the best main tank.
I will chuck my heels up on high ground if you need it.
Got you, got you.
I don't even know where to stand here, to be honest.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna just...
You stand, support is just stand, you stand with our Luna.
That's really it.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
You just hold one lane.
Yeah, you don't, you try not to...
My bad.
Yeah, this is good.
This is good.
We can see if they push the other way.
Yeah, if they go the other way, we'll rotate through the
center.
Moon Knight.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
Tunks.
If you need help, somebody's on top of the center.
Holy fucking Moon Knight duel there.
Oh, my fucking hook.
I fell.
That's fine.
I pushed off my blur.
Um, Penny, can you contest the high ground?
Yes.
Yeah, contest it.
Oh, I can't get up there.
What the fuck?
Oh, Byron, Howl by Lina?
Howl.
Get down, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
All right, you can drop up.
You can leave the high ground now because our...
Okay, okay, okay, got it.
There's no res.
He's breaking the floor.
You have the high ground.
There's no res.
Bro,
get down.
There's no res, so be careful.
There's a squirrel girl up here too.
What the heck?
Okay.
Moonite, Moonite, Moonite!
Moonite, Moonite!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, nice, nice, nice.
We left that.
Trying to help our...
so much, so much, so, I'm all here.
Save back, I'll save all, I'm out.
Wait for this, wait for this.
I'll, I'll, I'll, I'll.
No more else, no more else, no more else, no more else.
Can we get, Moonite, Moonite, please, Moonite, please,
Moonite, please, thank you.
Get the...
Support, support, support, support, nice, nice, nice.
I got one, I got one, I got one, I got one.
Oh my god.
Alright, no murals here, no, we got a build all here.
Careful, careful belt, careful belt, you're gonna wall out.
Careful, careful.
Okay, I have my old, I can stall.
Do we want the second nest near the supports?
Yeah, give any, put any of them.
Don't put it in the open, don't put it in the open.
Oh, he went back, I got a switch, I got a storm.
There's a storm, there's a storm.
Nice kill.
Uh, Yuzu hide, Yuzu hide, Yuzu hide, just hide.
You can alt us if you can.
It's Isa, Isa, I ult this.
Okay, got it, got it, got it.
Just alt this, Isa.
Break the squirrels, break the squirrels if you can.
Nice.
That was a zoning alt, got them off.
That's fine, I have res, I have res.
Just, um...
Res here, res here, res here.
Oh, never mind, don't res.
Don't rest.
Okay.
Never.
Rest.
Rest now.
I didn't have ulti.
No, you rest me.
I was trying to switch.
It's fine.
Fight this.
We're fighting.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
They're off the point.
They're back one.
Both healers are one.
Storm behind us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just...
She's one.
Nice.
I helped it.
I healed it.
No more else.
Jeff please, Jeff please, Jeff please.
He's in the floor.
We're pushing them back, we're pushing them back.
We're pushing them back.
I'm alting them.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Too dead.
Yeah, 30 seconds.
I have res here.
I'm gonna find a good place to res.
Down to 30 seconds.
I hear the jab.
I can hear him.
It's okay.
He doesn't have ulti.
He's just in the back.
Careful bell.
You're pushed up by yourself.
I'm just farming.
We'll see.
I'm just farming for you guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's good.
I bubble.
Random bullshit.
Go!
Here, they're gonna, they're gonna force.
They're gonna force.
They're gonna try to touch.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, Sennie.
Yeah, they come.
Here they come.
Portal, portal, portal, portal, portal.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
They're down one.
Rocket ult.
I can't, I can bubble.
I can't bubble.
I'm dead.
It's fine.
Oh, they took my portal.
They took my portal.
die portal first person that dies portal first person i got
it i got it i got it i have res but i got i got yeah yeah
just uh just use your res um i can strange i can strange i'm
i'm i'm already on it why wouldn't it click i couldn't all
signs my side might we have portal we have portal oh they
came don't come out don't leave leave leave leave use it
don't get in don't get in oh no what are they swallowing me
they swallowing me i couldn't i couldn't jump in the portal
Okay, so the thing is we have to use it.
You just don't have to go to a portal for us.
You wait But that's okay.
That's okay.
I was like a little confusing.
It's okay Get all good.
I think it's you want to say you can do Hawkeye for against
the Groot, right?
Yeah, yeah, I can switch now.
I was only playing Okay, so there was no walls I don't want
to go penny anymore.
Their Groot is breaking my shit.
Yeah, just swap Emma.
Yeah, I'll stay on rocket rocket's been working
Oh this is a nice spot oh damn blur he's in your face he
wants you come here come here i got you i got you guys got
it i got you guys help uh bail soon okay somehow the sharks
feeling should we drop down i have all here i'm gonna use it
drop down well here in three two one okay blur there's no
way dog we're not doing this big dog change change change
change change change Strange one.
Strange one.
Nice, nice, nice.
Got him, got him, got him.
Groot, Groot, please.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Right side, right side.
All right, you two, you hide for this fight.
You hide for this fight.
Luna, don't ult.
We all get wiped.
We don't use ults.
You two hide.
We all get wiped.
Let them use every ult they can.
And then we...
Got it, got it, got it.
We're here to bait ults here.
Oh, it's okay.
We have res.
I have res.
You don't have to reuse for res.
Yeah.
Blur's going on top again.
And he's going in our back lane.
Yeah, okay.
Just die, just die, just die here, die here, die here, die
here, die here, die here.
Let us die here.
Fight to the death.
Nice, nice.
Brace this, yes.
Oh, no.
Oh my god.
Oh, I thought this...
Oh, that was just a good counter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We had to...
It's fine, it's fine.
It's fine.
They used a lot of us.
We still have Luna.
We have Luna and Emma.
They use Groot ult.
We still have a lot.
We can contest.
Yeah, no, I have to play.
They only have strange arms.
You keep Lunal for Strange.
Keep Lunal for Strange.
That's all you need to do.
We can Emma ult this as well.
Oh my god.
I want to keep my ulti for Punisher.
That's okay.
Yeah, if it was like a done deal, yeah, we didn't have to
mag that.
That's okay.
I'm ulting this.
I'm alting this.
Nice, nice, nice.
They don't have cloak out.
We win this.
Alting.
Nice.
Focus on my alt.
They're on the back.
Support, support, support, support.
Yeah, we're good.
Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff.
Focus on Jeff.
He's a slippery one.
Can we get the rocket ulti, please?
I'm getting it.
I'm on it.
Thank you, thank you.
Focus, Jeff, please.
Jeff is the only one with ult.
Got him!
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
Punisher dead!
Here comes Rocket!
Jeff is coming back!
Great is one!
Good is one!
Nice!
Rocket!
Change me!
Nice!
Oh my god, nice.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Go to DP.
Go to DPS.
Oh, good job, guys.
He swaps.
Sorry about that, Rose, guys.
No, no, it's okay.
That's why it's like you have, when we say like...
They literally just countered your Rose.
Yeah.
He just had to like, uh, we just keep this comp.
Good job, head ass.
Okay.
Unless they start target batting, we could play other comps.
Yep.
Oh, she are.
That was awesome.
okay so you see when i say like hi for res you just go like
not even close to us basically already yeah it's like you go
like uh uh you just like hide essentially like you make sure
that they can't find you yeah yeah you just have to be away
from the fight but not too far away but for if you res
before the portal you rest outside the portal and then you
go in okay okay that's how you do It's Convergence.
Oh, man.
Or Nephi Convoy.
She picks.
Her team picks.
It'd be kind of cool if they did use guard, or you just so.
My least favorite of these is Tokyo.
Oh, hello.
Where are we going?
We run 3-3.
Got it, got it, got it, got it.
Do you guys remember what the 3-3 is?
Oh, is this on an Angelina?
What do we ban here?
three more dps we ben do you want ben bucky or hello hello
or stirren here
uh i don't i think bucky and then storm because i don't know
how i you say that and then we get our ass whoops i don't
want to leave the no more team up though oh for the snap
yeah i mean
He for me?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll do Hella then for the team to get rid of the team up.
We're doing Hella, right?
Like the soft counterate though.
Wait, wait, if he's...
Yeah, wait, hold on.
If he's playing Fantastic, we don't need to ban Hella.
If Fantastic is through.
Yeah.
What's...
Well, I don't think they're going to ban your Fantastic.
I'm going to be...
They didn't band Fantastic though.
Mm-hmm.
The band Namor instead.
I don't...
I don't want...
One of them got to go.
Hella?
Hella or Storm?
We do Hella, right?
Hello?
Okay, wait, is this a Jeff map?
Can that guy just wreck our shit again?
Yes.
Get rid of Storm.
Oh, Angie.
Two.
Um, yes.
50, 50.
Well, let's see which one is.
We'll do fine.
It's fine.
Pick Hella.
You pick Hella.
You pick!
Oh, Hawk.
Oh, okay.
They didn't ban my...
They didn't ban you.
So we can run her.
We run this.
Okay.
If they actually...
Lock him and make him sorry.
Come on, Heavenly.
Lock in and make him sorry.
Is it Loki or Adam?
If they run...
The thing is, we're attacking.
So the moment we see a Moon Knight, you can come back and
swap.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Tell him he's going to rue the day.
If we need to, you can go Invis and I can go Rocket.
Okay.
Alright.
Actually, here.
Yes, he attacks.
Oh, it's this.
one oh i i didn't even realize it was this one that's why
you run three three after okay wait are we not okay not no
no and defense in defense okay what are we doing now then is
he still running fantastic uh yeah yeah do this it still
works okay okay okay get your packs and the swap actions
give me my snack from the snack machine if they run moon
night i think triple deeps was working too or like do it
yeah or we swap the dps to moon night Yep.
Three, two, one.
Oh, let's see what they're doing.
I hear a Spider-Man.
Oh, no, that's the map.
Oh, your thing blocked it.
There is an Iron Man.
Iron Man.
Oh, he's so low.
That is so unlucky.
That guy was one HP.
I hit like, I just needed to hit a third shot.
Help our Emma!
I can't do anything.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I just got kicked into the enemy team, but now
they're...
Now they're walled in.
I don't have Envon.
No, I'm good.
It's fine.
Oh.
We might...
I got Blur!
I think I'm gonna play Mag into this.
We can still triple tank, but I'm gonna play Mag.
No, we don't triple tank on offense, do we?
No, no, it's fine.
We can still triple tank this.
It's fine.
No, just keep it, keep it, keep it.
I have all soon.
They have two characters that can be kind of a match.
Oh, this?
That's fine.
I put as many walls between us and her.
Spread out.
You got nothing?
Kill the Jeff if we can.
Oh, she lives.
We get Iron Man, Iron Man one, Iron Man one.
He's gone.
I have copies.
I got all.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm copying me.
Copy me.
Push up.
Pushing up.
What the fuck is this lag?
Oh, it's just...
Halting.
I'm bubbled.
I didn't bubble.
Got the healers.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
Good, good, good, good!
No more alts.
Help our group.
Get the group.
There's one.
Dairy group.
Nearly got him.
I got him.
Emma's low.
Help me.
I'm so glad I got too aggressive there.
That was my bad.
I really wanted that Emma kill.
Helper.
Yeah.
I was overextended.
Both me and Isa were too hungry compared to the healers.
Yeah, no, I was I wanted it too.
I just ran straight for fucking cloak.
I was like, I'm eating it looks good I want it.
You have to run moon night for this Magna this make all this
make all this.
No, oh no, I'm eating I got it to save the I'm saving you
for okay punish you.
Okay I can go moon night right now.
Yeah, go moon night go to moon night.
There's no reason.
Okay, well Finishing Nice, nice, nice.
Very good.
Okay, Iron Man, Iron Man top, Iron Man top, Iron Man top.
Nice, nice, nice.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
They're down to both DPS.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
They're down to both DPS, please.
Help her, help her, help her, help her.
Jeff one, Jeff one, Jeff one, Jeff one.
Jeff one, Jeff one.
You gotta be, okay, nice.
I'm choked.
Okay, it's fine.
Get the grip, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I got kicked.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna copy, I'm gonna copy.
Yeah, yeah, copy me, copy me.
Where's the Iron Man?
Iron man behind us behind us focus on him.
He's hiding.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna look.
I'm gonna keep my, I don't know.
They're cloaked.
Cloaked cloak cloak cloak cloak.
Oh my gosh.
Nice.
I got their, I got their gear.
I got their gear.
I hear Iron man.
Iron man.
Focus on Iron man.
He's low.
They're not on the, they're only one on the point.
Nice.
He's dead.
I'm alting this.
Jeff is alting.
Spread out.
I got grabbed, I got grabbed.
I got grabbed.
I'm inside.
I'm pushing it in.
I'm using my altar, pushing it in.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
There's a portal, portal.
We have to portal.
I'm portaling, I'm portaling, I'm portaling.
If you can just back up, don't die.
The Loki, don't die.
Don't die.
You can.
Okay, okay, okay.
Don't die.
Just...
I'm trying to.
Okay.
Let's go.
He's gonna have, uh, he's gonna have Iron Metal here.
Oh my gosh, he's gonna have to.
I blocked it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Can we get a, can we get?
Where's our rest?
We have a rest.
Ironman.
Player on card.
He can die.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm shooting Ironman.
I'm shooting Ironman for you.
He's one.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Groot, Groot.
Focus on Groot.
Groot.
he is very low okay okay nice nice next deal nice nice nice
all right i'm gonna stay um i'm gonna stay on rocket come
here wait there's someone nice nice nice okay they're on um
okay we gotta save we got to go back to mag here uh we all
and one of i'll do strange all first and then go to mag okay
and then we have to swap oh wait we can actually uh i think
luna's better I'm gonna go.
I all and then switch the storm they switched the storm.
yeah, we need mag and I'll swap to Luna.
I'll swap to Luna Yeah Are you our only flyers defense or do
we need a DPS his can I guess which We can we blur back the
fuck up uh, I can switch.
Yeah, I'm great One of them fell off nice nice.
I got some nice.
No more else no more else.
No more else.
Got it.
We win this.
We win this it's time to face your fear get that get that
puncher get that puncher nice push cut yeah yeah yeah three
three three on cart three on cart three on cart three on
cart oh no i'm gonna switch okay okay okay okay okay back
off back off i'm gonna use all here your walled your walled
look your walled i'm gonna use all here for uh jeff jeff
jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff jeff there he is spread
out i couldn't get up what the is going on man i'm gonna get
tossed off i'm gonna get tossed off yeah it's okay it's okay
it's okay it's okay We're even.
He's dead though.
I have res.
I'm switching.
I'm switching now.
I'm holding.
I want the storm.
Get the storm.
Oh man.
Never mind.
I don't know if I should anymore.
Oh no.
You did double copy.
Yeah.
This way.
I'm going to try to back off here.
I'm going to go Luna.
I'm going Luna here.
Okay.
Back off.
All I ever wanted to do was seem really.
I feel like myself again.
Oh my god.
One DPS, they're down one, down one, down one.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Push up a bit, push up a bit.
They have to back up.
They have to kite this now.
Nice, two, two, two.
They're down two, down two.
Push up, push up, push up, push up.
Don't be scared.
Jack down, Jack down.
Down three, down three.
Focus on those Emma.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma.
She's one.
I got her.
Quick, quick, quick, quick, quick.
Focus on group.
He's by himself.
I want him.
Good one, good one, good one!
Good one!
Oh, I'm dead.
Starb!
I'm not too dead!
Queen, Queen!
Nice!
Thanks so much!
I like the cold!
Emma!
Focus fully on Emma!
She is just...
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice!
Alright.
Oh my gosh, we'll keep this.
Okay.
Where's my...
Can I have my Hawk out back?
No.
Hmm.
Groot is one.
It's Moonnight.
You want me to switch to Adam out there?
No, no more else here.
No more else here.
Okay.
uh sorry unless we get a pick unless we get a pay here storm
pure storm i think storm my ulti swap now swap now use use
this swap now this is last fight uh try back off let me yeah
yeah we're still good i can't do anything i it's fine just
play keep playing this keep playing this but use moonlight
so you can still be loki now i have next up use uh you have
to use invis if you're in danger.
I'll save my Luna up for...
Nice, nice.
Grude, Grude, please.
He's low.
Oh, I'm blocking heals.
I'm blocking heals.
Grude dead.
I'm on the backline.
Nice, nice, nice.
I got the Emma.
Keep me out.
I got to be.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Shoot the storm, shoot the storm.
Shoot the storm, shoot the storm, shoot the storm.
Invis, Invis, focus on Invis.
Focus on Invis.
We can kill her.
Emma, Emma, focus on Emma.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes!
Oh, nice.
Oh.
Oh my god, my eyes are burning.
They've been open for so long.
Alright.
We won 3-3.
Okay.
Yep, yep, yep.
You'll need a top notch team to win this one.
You want Adam?
Yeah, Adam, we'll do...
Adam Loki is the thing and we just have to sustain.
Okay.
I just keep resing when you say that.
You go, I...
Yeah.
We do this.
No, 3-3, 3-3.
Fail.
Bill?
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Oh.
Go back.
Oh my god.
I was like blanking out.
like do you want emma here or or uh strange uh they don't
really have many projectiles besides storm and i mean yeah
you guys you guys have enough shields all right after we
lose first one we just swapped to what we were playing yep
okay 30 seconds before you attack get ready done done we
need the mag just yeah just remember the mag for the uh i
hear you jam it out heavenly yeah it called you know we can
we can push up we can push up here we can push up here we
can push up oh yeah we push up we play around this corner
yeah push up this corner come on come on come on come on uh
you don't have to push up you don't have to push up you
might need to do soap on for them but other than that you
don't need to push up push up um push up a bit push up with
them push up with them i was looking for flyers yeah
They're just going to run.
Nice pull.
Shield up.
Turrets up.
Turrets down.
Good job.
He's running up on me.
I have to put a wall on myself.
Where's one?
Nice.
Where's hell?
We can push up a finger.
I got a res.
All right.
Moon Knight, where was that?
Can we get Monks?
Nice kill.
Down one.
Let's keep playing this.
I'm backing out.
You're fine.
I have no shield.
I have no bubble for you.
It's fine.
Just keep fighting out.
Keep fighting out.
I already used my Involve.
All right.
They have a storm.
I just saw it.
Yeah, it's fine.
That's like the counter for it.
All right.
I'm going to go.
We'll use the...
We'll use...
Oh, I have no.
If you can...
I have...
I have res.
Yeah, yeah.
Use res.
You can.
Yeah, I'm gonna copy you and I'm gonna don't Spread out
spread out spread out Yeah, no one oh Okay, well he was
punished anyway.
Sorry I got all I'm ultimately I'm with you I'm with you
with you with you are nice.
He used to hide you to hide you to hide you used to hide
hiding hiding hiding.
There you go No, he's boxed the fuck in the monster game.
I'm dead.
Lur one Blair one.
Wait, yeah Res, res, res, res, res, oh wait, no, actually,
yeah, yeah, yes, yes, yes, yes, okay.
Where's out of the healing?
Oh, it was too far.
It's fine, it's fine.
Wait, no, I'm back, I'm back, I'm back, I'm back!
I'm dead.
Oh, no, it's fine, it's fine.
Just die on point, die on point, die on point, die on point,
die on point, die on point.
We have to die here, we have to die here.
Just die here, just die here.
We're dead, we're dead.
Yeah, just keep, stay on court.
No, stay, stay, stay, stay.
We stay the cop.
And then we all meet up there and then wait, just wait, wait
for us.
You want me to portal?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, we just go.
We just go.
We can make it.
I was so unlucky because Blur was just waiting for it.
Like, wouldn't let me use my...
Oh, there's a gap!
There you are.
Are you ready?
There's no more, Jeff.
I'm switching the thing.
Okay.
Oh, we have to go in with...
You can just go in.
Yeah.
I'll be able to catch him.
I'm like right there.
I'm right there.
That's fine.
We have point.
Get someone help.
Someone grab the healers.
I separated the healers.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I have copy here.
The healers are still in the back.
They're still boxed in.
Yo, man, he was boxing.
We can get, we can get nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Storm over here.
We get point, point, point, please.
Yeah, we're getting nice, nice, nice, nice.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Care, care, care.
We don't have to, we can push, we can play here.
We can play here.
It's fine.
Okay.
I will see.
Don't.
Don't save your all for last fight.
Save your all for last fight.
Bell, back up.
Back up.
You can.
This is like, we saved it for last fight.
What if the thing was blue?
Back up around the corner.
We're too far.
Okay.
Yeah, ready to use the invisible.
When he lands that ult, I'm going to pull him away from the
point.
Oh, no, no, no.
No.
Oh, fucking mag ate it.
Damn it.
All right.
I'm blocking them off the point.
Oh, my God.
That's fine.
I'm dying.
They double healer ulted.
I'm dead.
What the fuck is happening?
Oh, I don't know.
I can portal.
No, I got I got he.
Wait, I don't.
I can't.
Hold on.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
I can't.
Swaps, swaps, swaps, swaps, swaps.
Swaps now.
Okay.
Or are you going mag?
I'm just saying Thing.
Thing is really good against them.
We still need Mag, though.
We're...
Oh, wait.
They don't have any Jeff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just dropping off.
It's faster.
Let's go.
Go toe to toe with him.
Get his ass.
We have to back up fully.
Back up fully.
We don't need to feed them all.
Don't feed them all.
We wait.
I'll level round and then I'm going to ult them from behind.
Sorry.
All right.
Let's go.
We can...
He's not here yet.
Yeah, it's fine.
We can poke here.
We can poke because he's almost there.
I will copy and viz here.
You have to hide for this.
Okay.
Hiding, hiding.
Ooh, they tried to push me!
A second time!
I'm hiding.
Nice, nice.
Help, bell, help, bell, help, bell.
I'm helping.
This is an alt.
They forced Taylor ult.
They forced Taylor ulti.
Just keep hiding.
Just like... Just like...
It's fine.
We can die here.
Die here.
And then you should get ready for the res.
Get ready for the res.
Okay.
Yeah, just keep see just keep hiding.
Just keep hiding.
See we're still sustaining Don't use all don't use off.
Don't use invas.
Don't use it.
We just die here That's just a waste.
It's such a waste right start the res.
Start the res now start.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're down one, by the way.
They're still down one.
There you go.
Nice.
I'm coming back.
Mag's dead.
Moon's dead.
Nice Heavenly.
Nice.
Still down two.
Down two, down two, down two, down two.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to keep, oh no.
I can't contest the cloak ult.
Yeah, I'm trying to keep, oh no.
Yeah, we're dead.
Just die, just die, just die here, just die here.
I'm dying here, just die here.
Just die here or go back.
All right, that's fine.
I'm gonna go.
By the way, they don't have, they only have rocket ulti.
They only have Rugged Elite Team.
I'm going Rocky here so we can have Rez here.
What the fuck?
Get out, get out, get out.
This is so bad, this is so bad.
It's fine, I have Rez.
I got Rez.
You get picked up by the Rez?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's fine, it's fine.
I have my ult for this fight.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
What the heck?
Eat my ult.
Fuck, I mean, should I go.
Need a heal?
Use it if you get, never mind.
I'm good.
All the way.
Oh, okay.
Can I, can I?
Kaino, Kaino, Kaino, Kaino, if you can, Kaino, if you can,
we don't need...
Yeah!
They're down on the healers.
They're down.
Don't play too aggressive.
Don't play.
Okay.
I'm backing up.
They're back.
They're going to need it.
We don't need it.
Gotcha, bitch.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
They're going to TP.
We got point.
Focus on storm.
Nice.
Storm dead.
I have all here.
I'm dead.
Nice.
We did it.
Oh my god.
We fucking did it.
We did it.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
The day.
Oh, that's not blue.
Oh my god.
I got four-time MVP.
Look at you go, dude.
Yeah.
Look at that shit on a regiment.
Oh, my God.
You have officially attained bragging rights, Valilla.
Now you can say whatever you want.
I'm too nervous to even bragg.
Let's go.
Good job, guys.
I'm so proud of you guys.
Yes, good job.
Oh, my God.
That was awesome.
Thank you for the carry.
Thank you for everyone.
shout out show down gomez shout out shout out gomez shut up
the blue thing what if the thing is blue oh my god that was
a really that was a really good game they were saying yeah
yeah we had to we had to we did a really counter soft so
many times that we mastered 3-3 too.
We mastered it.
That was my first time doing 3-3 outside of our like one
tryout.
We freaking did it, guys.
Wow, you guys are so wow, amazing.
You guys are correct.
Doki, yeah, that's so sick.
Can you come to the Mouse and Monkey Channel?
Can I bring my team?
Yeah, let me ask for it.
Let's all go in there.
Let's all celebrate together.
Hold on, hold on.
Hold on.
Let me let me.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, my God.
We were undefeated, guys!
Yay!
We were undefeated!
That's crazy.
Also, apparently my stream was lagging the entire time.
I'm so sorry, guys.
The final match.
Everything was lagging.
Oh, my God.
My game was lagging.
My...
My brain is lagging.
Shout out Doki.
the call outs yes yes amazing shot calling thank you guys
thank you my i felt like i was going my brain was like 500
miles per hour i hate thinking on the spot it's amazing it's
amazing i'm glad it's not best of one for this turn for the
finals i mean yeah yeah yeah no this is why i like best of
three because then like we can easily figure things out next
game yeah oh Oh my god, look at us 5-1.
Oh my god, we did it.
Good job guys, great teamwork.
Good job, everyone.
We all played a part.
It's a team game.
We all did our part.
Give me one second now.
I will bring you all in there.
Oh, okay, nice.
All of y'all.
We really ate that, y'all.
Yeah.
oh my god that was great that you were able to pick up
adam's stuff in like one game lord headass lord headass was
doing some major work yeah yeah oh my god they thought they
thought we only had one dps player little did they know i
know little did they know heavenly was our secret weapon
okay but they let kiku take invisigirl oh it's true 52 000
healing 52 000 yeah we all played a part we're such congrats
guys you you deserve it uh feel free to go into the main
chat mouse monkey at the right time okay all right thank you
no problem thank you thank you well look at this
coming in right now.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Oh, I think...
I have to ask.
Yeah.
What do you do, baby?
So, obviously, that game was amazing, first of all, very fun
to watch.
The first game, it looked pretty tough.
What was the ultimate shift you guys did in the second game
to kind of change the tides?
Oh, it's easy.
You want to know what I did?
What did you do?
I turned my monitor on this time.
That's true.
I think like the other teams didn't know we actually had a
second DPS player that we put on tank.
So when they target banned our first DPS player, we're like,
all right, roll swap.
So then obviously Heavenly has an insane hot guy.
And so, but Lila was our, yeah, it was, I mean, he got
target banned after that.
Yeah.
He was too nasty.
but I'm still getting that W.
What was the point?
You should have been Groot.
I could have been Grooter in the building, baby.
What are you talking about?
And yes, and they obviously target banned our support
backline, too.
So we had to play an entirely new support comp that we
haven't really practiced with.
And Yuzu had to pick up how to play Adam for the last two
games.
So really insane that she was able to do that for us.
It was really cool to watch, especially the fights towards
the end there where it was like two people were dropped from
each team what what kind of comms are you giving to stand to
like in that situation or are you just shutting up and let
them do their thing kill
i guess like when we're down too we just yeah yeah we just
be like focus this week we have the odds to win this fight
like just just or like or just die on the card like we all
just die on the card stall the card as long as we can and
then you know we got some time out of it and we don't
teams had like a really strong player like at least one or
two but our team had really good comms and i think that's
like ultimately what helped us the most we just listened
when we were told what to do yeah yeah i thought we were
really like well rounded which is really nice i feel like we
could flex into anything or like most of us could flex into
any role that was required which is really helpful that i
think gave us like an advantage against the other ones you
guys played a lot of different characters and even doki
played loki at the end which we didn't see yeah we were like
Yeah, it's an actual strat, like the 3-3, like three tanks,
three supports.
So I fucked up how you're supposed to play Loki.
You're supposed to like copy the atom and then do like, like
basically do like a never-ending res fight.
But then the moment I copied, like the storm was like right
next to me.
And I was like, oh, okay.
I guess no alts for anyone.
But yeah, no, it's, we are all so well-rounded.
Like no one can really target ban us because all of us were
not really one tricks.
so we're able to like play other types of characters and
change your comps um so i'm really proud of my team for that
i noticed that you guys also didn't ban uh jeff in the other
games did you feel like jeff was a problem or you had it on
the control on that map he was a problem he was very
disruptive yeah it's so yeah and then we figure it out we're
just like just hold mag out for him like puked the fuck yeah
the magneto shield seemed to address a lot of those issues
but then storm also was very very frustrating it looked like
for you guys to deal with yeah yeah and i think blower in
general was just very hard to deal with he's just a good
player yeah yeah he's a very moments where the healing
battle just seemed like it never ended on both sides you
were just like come on just die triple support baby triple
support yeah it was kind of from the from like commentating
it's like oh he's gonna i know he's just full help well how
do they but that was that was such amazing games and i i
hope you guys had fun i know we had so much fun thank you so
much for our hosting great i'm so happy i'm so proud of you
guys thank you for the invite thank you for having us it's
really fun i'm really proud of my team didn't expect us to
go to the finals and you're such a good team leader yes
amazing she wasn't so good team leader oh my god i was
informative yeah i will give a shout out to our coach super
gomez too because he was like he helped us out like figuring
out comps and stuff with me before we went into this
tournament so like huge shout out and he also like stayed
around to coach some of individually some of the players as
well so i think i need you to coach me yeah you need to be
my Oh, man, I feel so stupid, though.
No, what are you saying?
You're so good.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Seriously, thank you.
It was a lot of fun.
And I hope you guys are a good day.
And thanks for wedding and congrats, man.
Congrats, guys.
You guys were all good.
Thank you.
This is sick.
This was awesome.
Shout out Goat Mez.
All right.
Congrats, guys.
See you guys later.
Bye.
Look how we are.
Oh, shit.
We all dreamed to go down here.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
GGs, guys.
I'm so proud of all of you guys.
Great games.
Good job, guys.
I had a lot of fun.
You guys were very fun to play with.
Yeah.
Yeah, wait.
Gomez wants to say something to us.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Whoa, whoa.
Come on.
Whoa.
I see you.
I mean, the time is over, so.
Yeah.
It's over.
Yeah, yeah.
You're coming here.
Come on.
Pull up, girl.
Pull up here.
Pull up.
Don't be shy.
I never doubted any of you.
I never doubted any of you in my fucking life.
You guys put in the work.
Popping in the fuck off.
You guys did it, Ta.
You guys literally fucking did it since the beginning.
Yeah!
I knew you guys were going to do it, Ta.
I literally made it, Ta.
I love this game.
This game is the best.
I love Marvel.
Dude, I forgot my Fugies die.
Hold on, I need to change it.
What a good game.
What is that?
Why is this Fugies?
That was awesome.
I forgot.
Okay, okay.
I was in my seat jumping.
I was watching Heavenly's POV.
There was a point where he dropped his own little own music.
He hockey ulted, locked in, and killed four people.
I was literally jumping in my seat.
and it was the last push i i was on a i was on a royal
palace i don't remember what map it was but like it popped
you guys it was i was i never that was like i was too hyped
that's proud of me i am proud i am proud i'm so proud
everybody is we learned how to play together really well and
i think that was like the best part of our team yeah we like
heavenly today was the first time we all played together as
a team too Yeah.
The synergy was just there.
It was just there.
I was like watching all of you just completely just do
everything together.
Like it was just clicked.
Everything just clicked.
It just clicked.
Oh my God.
Guys, we won, we won 7.5k.
Well, not individually, but you know, split between six of
us.
1.25.
Yeah.
1.25k guys.
Look at that.
Oh, really?
Okay.
I just wanted to compete.
Yeah, I just wanted to compete.
Y'all can keep this.
All right, I'll get his cut.
I'll do that.
Oh, yeah.
You don't get the coach cut?
I'll take it.
It's mine.
I was actually going to ask for like 20 bucks from each one
of you.
But I thought it works too.
You know, that works.
Not Heavenly will pay the tab.
All right, I'll take this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my.
Gee, geez.
I'm so proud of all you guys.
It was really nice to meet all of you guys that I haven't
met before.
And it was really fun to play with you guys.
Yeah.
I'm so glad.
I'm not going to lie.
No, you first.
Please, you're going to say something way nicer than what
I'm going to say.
Trust me.
No, it's okay.
It's just coming into this.
I was really like nervous and intimidated by everybody.
And this felt like the most welcoming like group.
And I was so happy just chatting with you all and meeting
you all.
I'm so happy.
Thank you guys for like playing with me or like we play with
you guys.
I'm so...
You killed it, dude.
You killed it.
Our MVP.
Always MVP.
Yeah, nah.
They gave me props.
of the round but it was oh yeah yeah you you let us do the
finals you got us to the finals like glories always happen
oh what the i'm really happy that this win was with all of
you guys it was very very fun yeah i'm so happy this is
awesome this was great i uninstalled i will probably stay
uninstalled let me know if you need me just call me back in
i'll come back a second time yeah for sure for sure all
right thank you so much see i'll see all of you guys around
it was really nice to meet everybody new and see everybody
older you all have a wonderful day continuing to stream uh
probably me for like 30 minutes all right i'll read okay
yeah i'm gonna read actually don't actually don't do that
i'm on youtube so i can't read no no no no stop rates at one
hour already turned that off can't
wait goman, start your stream right now goman, start your
stream.
I'm not streaming.
Start your stream.
I'm good.
I think I'm okay.
Oh man.
Nah, raid someone else.
Cause if I'm getting off in 30, that's not waste of a raid.
But you can choose a different person to raid.
We give you our numbers that you can make someone's day with
the number.
oh you know who's okay you know who's still gonna i don't
know if he's gonna stay live but blur is live still oh yeah
give him is it just is it just blur it's blur flavors with
the z yeah he literally tried to one no that's not worth
worthy right that's a worth worth yeah one v4 yeah he was
locking in so hard he wanted me dead bro he like chased me
across the map
He chased me on Storm.
Oh, he's got it in him.
He's a killer.
That's why I was so sad we fought against each other.
We should have been on the same team.
You two on the same team would have been too much.
Yeah, it would have been.
Yeah, you two are on the same team at DPS.
Like, we just, you just get, you'll just win.
That was so much fun.
GGs, guys.
I'm going to say goodbye to chat and everything.
Yeah.
I'm going to say goodbye.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks for playing.
Bye, love.
Thank you, Gomez.
yeah of course i'm proud of all of you i'm proud of all of
you thank you everyone for showing up i'm proud of all of
you i'm proud of all you bye-bye oh my god hello um past
chat this is future doki so um you guys might not might not
see me yet uh because i can't believe we started lagging in
the finals like out of oh my it pisses me I'm so sad I'm so
sad that we started lagging in the finals it makes me so
goddamn sad but again thank you again um thank you again to
uh Iron Mouse and Seedog for the invite I was so stressed
out I didn't think I was gonna make it to the finals I
thought we were getting knocked out right away I was this
was the most stressful fucking thing I've ever done um I was
honestly incredibly stressed out I thought I thought I was
gonna lose.
So, um, um, I, I, I'm so happy for my team.
I'm really happy for, um, how well everybody performed.
I, everyone was practicing so much and I was just like, oh
no, like, I hope we'll be okay.
I, I hope, I hope it will be okay, guys.
Actually, let me, I don't know.
If I restart my OBS, will it?
I don't know.
I don't know if it'll work through anything.
It's really weird.
I don't know what's wrong with my internet right now.
I'm going to do a test.
Okay, you're not internet test.
This is the future, Joki.
Run internet test.
No, it's fine.
It's literally fine right now.
I don't understand.
Is it really on YouTube's side?
Wait, I'm trying.
trying again
I'm trying again to see if it's on YouTube side or if it's
on my side no I'm fine my internet's fine it's like it's at
a thousand it's at 900 900 wait okay what's the upload
though what is the upload wait if I stop do stop stream and
restart stream will it fuck with stream
yeah i'm what my internet is fat yeah i'm past future toky
is talking to past chat right now
no clue wait are are our other channels also dying or is it
just me
okay okay just it was just me okay we're gonna what if I
stop okay all right I'm gonna restart I'm gonna restart oh
my god oh YouTube stream had some stutters too
if you start probably fixed the delay but the vaude yeah if
the vaude might be cooked right now okay i don't want to
cook the vaude sad face
okay oh there are reports oh is youtube down okay let's
check oh shit yeah never mind yeah never mind youtube down I
also checked is YouTube down, Lamal.
I think it's Cloud.
Cloud's there.
I'm like, what's the outage?
Whoa, that's a lot of...
Yeah, I was like, wait, that's a lot of reports right now.
Okay, not just me.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
It's not...
yeah yeah it's not just me thank god is it yeah thank god
it's not just me right now whoa thank goodness okay uh oh my
gosh okay guys when you okay when we okay when we get to the
part okay uh tell me when you guys get to the part where I
say goodbye.
I talk more about tournament in Good Night Dragons.
And then alright guys.
Okay, I'm going to talk more about the entire tournament.
When I get to the part where I say goodbye.
So, as always everybody, say hi to Rhea Posh, check.
Get a bit of a round to get that blood flowing.
You said it for me, it's a bed.
deserve it thank you guys thank you for all the support that
really means a lot um this is crazy i did not expect to win
um i just i had like a breakdown last night because i almost
dropped out of the tournament tournament because i was under
so much stress and i really appreciate the organizers and
like cdog comforting me because like i i had so much to lose
in a way where like i i i know i had so much pressure and so
many eyes on me for that tournament and i legitimately
thought like i don't know if we could do it like i i just
hope we win the game like all these other teams they look
these players are all so so good and i'm just a support
player i don't i don't know i'm just a support player i i
don't know if if i can do like all but like i don't know if
i can pick up you know support doesn't have that much of an
impact so i didn't know if as a supporter i could do much
for my team because you know i all i could do is just heal a
little bit better like but um thank you guys thank you guys
i'm happy i stayed on um i still don't know if i'm gonna do
future if you should be right at those tournaments because
it's very stressful with a balancing thing so um i don't
know i don't know i'm like in the crossroads for it but
thank you guys and yeah i'll see you guys later today for
good night dragons bye guys